[Music]
i
but i get frustrated when someone i
really love comes over and we start
talking
and i'm like save it but then i'm like
what am i doing like we can always just
repeat it but we were just
we're gonna jump right into a
conversation about her special which
is out now yes on comedy central
and i was just telling her how
disgustingly jealous i am of her title
because it's such a good title
this is so nice of you tell me about it
it's called hot for my name
get it my name is esther pavitskiy and
it's the
ugliest name in the world my last name
is coming so i'm not super compassionate
but yes i see where you're coming from
but then i was saying
the title i love you for your sweat one
of your specials is so
weird because i don't really like the
funny punny titles like i'm not really
into that i'm not a pun person but
just having your special be called i
love you and then the imagery that you
use
is so psychotic i'm like oh whitney's
crazy that's what it is
that's that's what's funny about her my
second but yes my second special was
called i love you
and i wanted it to be really ominous and
aggressive
and i scare every man yeah totally i was
just like i wanna be alone forever how
do i figure this
out i had just gone through a really bad
breakup and
i was still in the codependent place of
thinking relationships ended because you
loved them too much
i used to think there was such a thing
as loving someone too much and it scared
them and like
they couldn't handle my love when in
reality that
quote unquote love was just
micromanaging martyring
control control trying to change them
yuck um my love was actually like
emotional abuse
uh and so i i wanted to
make a post and i hate funny posters
yeah i hate funny posters i hate
silly shit i like my first special ever
i did kind of do a funny like i think a
lot of female comics like
we feel like we have to be like overly
sexual or something in the beginning
it's
before we kind of like at least me
personally and uh it was called money
shot which is
also a great name it is a great name
it's not bad
it's not bad but i was like naked and i
had like
that was kind of awesome but like i
think i was just like topless i just was
like well who
i didn't know who i was i was like am i
this person am i raunchy like who
am i like and uh the i love you special
the poster i
wanted to rip my chest open so
scary in the poster so scary
and it gives you nightmares don't google
it i actually do
your algorithm will be jacked for a
while and
they couldn't do it with um special
effects
so we rented a cadaver in van nuys and
they cut
the cadaver open i'm so
and they photographed it and then
i had to pretend i was ripping my chest
open and they put
the photo are you serious of the open
cadaver
photoshopped it in yeah how did you get
this way
how wait my thing is unless you do it
right don't do it at all
i do like that i was so committed i was
talking about this yesterday i was like
i was hiking with my lover and i saw
christmas lights on a house that were
like crooked and not done well and i
literally was like
what's the point like why even bother
this story ends with you getting on a
ladder and pissing them i'm walking out
because you're it's too much like
you do it right or don't do it at all
that's like my mentality
okay i have before we even get into
anything i have an announcement for your
listeners and that is that
if you're a fan of whitney's there's
something that i know about her that you
guys need to know
whitney is the o.g of skincare
to the degree that you you'll never even
understand
10 years ago i would show up to the
comedy store and it'd be all guys
all guys and then there'd be one woman
whitney cummings whose face
was dripping wet it was it was
honestly really scary she was it was
like 11 o'clock at night maybe it was
like 12 o'clock at night she was just
glistening oil to the point where guys
would be like what is going on like
does she know and it's truly that you
were ahead of the skincare curve you
were
just seruming and oiling
and i don't know if you knew but it was
you were the og of the
care i looked like a jellyfish at all
times in my twenties
um i want i always start are you okay do
you need tissue no no
i'm fine i always crying i by the way
that wasn't serums those were tears
i was wet i was soaking wet uh me being
the only woman in the comedy store in my
20s was very traumatizing
we'll get to that in a minute but i
always start the podcast with asking the
guests if we're friends
i sure as hell hope so i've i've been
trying so
hard for a decade i'm i feel like i
finally arrived
i'm you know for a fact i'm obsessed
with you
i'm obsessed with you and chelsea and
natasha yeah the three of you
i just i want framed photos of all of
you in one room at my house like
you know i i'm obsessed with you so if
you will allow me to be your friend
yes well i really want to talk about our
friendship because
i it's interesting i feel like you and i
have recently trauma bonded
yeah very hard during the pandemic i
feel like this invisible
murderer virus has brought us together
correct i when you and i first met i was
not taking on new friends
i remember no i know
i didn't have any openings and i was at
capacity
um there was a waiting list this is a
story about persistence
and i think i have to be honest with you
like for the longest time
and i and you know people have seen
what's going on in the comedy world in
the news in the podcast world like
i the environment of comedy
was so toxic for so long that
i think i sort of adjusted accordingly
and
um put blinders on figured out a way to
go into comedy clubs
not connect with anybody put on all my
armor
and just not entrench without anybody
and just figure out a way to get in and
get the fuck out which by the way is
right like you had the right
plan of action like i that's why i
wasn't like oh
you know screw her no i knew what you
were about and why you were like
that because look i i'm just saying i
get it and i'm
i'm i subscribe so i think when you
started
coming to the comedy show when i first
started knowing you i was already
this well-oiled machine of you get in
and you do your job and you get the fuck
out
which made me love you even more
[Laughter]
that is called stockholm syndrome for
everyone listening so i remember just
going if you stay and you hang out
you're going to be called a slut you're
going to be called a whore you're going
to be called
ugly people are going to oily wet oily
wet people are going to be jealous of
your luminous opalescent skin
game i ha you know it's funny people
make fun of how shiny i used to be yes i
used to put oil all over my face all the
time because
i had such bad acne my whole life a lot
of people don't know i was on
accutane twice i went on accutane when i
was 16
and when i was 21 that's how bad my
cystic acne was are you night blind from
it
that's a real thing wait what's night
blind when you can't see in the dark
anymore from accutane accutane is so
severe oh accutane is it even fda
approved i don't i don't think
there you have to take birth control the
same time you take accutane and you have
to
get blood tests every month to prove
that you're not pregnant because
babies would be deformed and it's linked
to suicide it's a link to a lot of
fucked up shit i did not know night
blindness was one of them but
a lot of stuff is starting to make sense
we should turn the lights off and see if
you're okay
no wait i don't i don't know i don't go
in front of a camera
without at least four giant lights
around me um
i but i am gonna look into that because
i've had a couple weird run-ins with
coyotes at night that i feel like could
have been prevented if i didn't take
accutane oh god
but what accutane does by the way one of
the side effects of accutane i wrote all
about this uh
in my book is anal bleeding and i
remember just being like
worth it it didn't deter me didn't slow
me down that's how bad
my acne was when i was a teenager like
the really cystic deep ones that
you feel and you know when you feel it
that this is gonna be like a three-week
thing this thing's gonna be it's gonna
take about three weeks to run its course
it hurts it's just dread the dread of
knowing i'm gonna have this
volcanic eruption for the next you know
and then a scar maybe forever
a scar and then your squeal like i just
i think that you know
when you're a teenager your appearance
it's
good bad needs to be you know um
therapy who cares the point is that
that's what this is before filters we
didn't have nashville filter
we didn't have hefe we didn't have the
dog ear filter
like you looked like what you looked
like it was like really hard
you know you we didn't have we couldn't
add brightness to our photos we had to
see each other
in person and all of our imperfections
and i remember
like during lunch i would go into the
bathroom and just hide because i was so
embarrassed about my skin
and uh what i learned finally after
playing whack-a-mole with these
really drying agents salicylic acid
zip creams the things that just fry your
face would exacerbate it
and a dermatologist finally told me that
your oil production glands actually
overcompensate when you dry your skin
out
so the best thing you can do for oily
broken out skin even though it's a total
uh goes against all instincts it's
totally
um anathema to what you think you should
do you should put oil on oily skin
because then your oil glands will start
producing
less oil it's crazy the 90s
ruined our lives okay oil-free face wash
everything we bought was oil-free we
were eating
fat freeze like knack wells fat free
cookies
that actually had way more calories way
more sugar way more sugar
it's it was we were doing it all wrong
so it's so against
remember lester potato chips that was
some anal leakage right there
vitamin d deficiencies and anal leakage
between my accutane and my olestra laced
potato chip
ships shit potato chips
you need diapers at all times but so i
started then dousing my face and oil at
all times and then i stopped breaking
out which i know
feels so counterintuitive but it really
works that first time you put oil on
your skin after being trained not to
is scary but yeah it's crazy because
your skin is so perfect now thank you
well thank you i feel like you're a real
oil
thank you i believe strongly in in
lubing up your face if you right now
were to tell me one
oil that i'd like need just give me one
um you know well i gave you one
in your little thank you package for
coming which is a serum that i use
um that has grape seed oil in it i would
say grape seed and tomato seed oil are
my number one oils
okay yes so number one and number one
there's a
tie um tomato seed i've never really
heard talked about i feel like you're
the only one on the tomato seed oil
because i don't want to tell anyone
because then it'll get sold out and
people will start having my secrets and
then
it'll fuck up the bell curve do we need
to cut this out i feel bad
like i also uh recently discovered an
oil called aparra epara
black owned great thing um uh to buy but
also just an incredible oil that i
become obsessed with i also put
different kind of oils on different
parts of my
face okay the thicker oils go around the
eye and on the eyelid whitney always has
to do a little extra than everybody else
okay we will not be out
done by anyone so i want to talk about
our relationship
because i think there's there's a lot to
discuss and watching your special which
by the way
not only made me laugh and i have been
dead inside
for a solid decade made me laugh
this actually really bothers me this is
when you know someone special is funny
when another comedian just gets like
annoyed at it it's like fuck like
i can watch a special and normally i'll
know what the punchline is gonna be
i'm like i know where it's going i was
surprised i was dazzled
my lover was watching it a man
plot twist i know my hair is probably
throwing you off with the kind of people
i
what gender i date but he was laughing
so hard
he did a spit take like a cartoon
lucille ball spit tank
and i filmed it for you i said it to you
so great i i so here here's the here's
the highest praise i can give
esther's comedy special even men think
it's funny
that's how good it is men even like it
i'm as surprised as you are trust me i
literally was gonna be like i need to
watch esther special can you just sit
here and watch
and he was enjoying it he rewinded a
couple of things it was really funny
did he love my dad i feel like my dad is
the star of my spirit i love your dad
and i
agree um but i want to
first say i feel like my relationship
with you
is very it's and it's recently changed
but i've always felt a very protective
uh instinct towards you but in not in a
good not in a healthy way
no that's even better because i really i
like that in a very controlling
codependent aggression i'm using trigger
trigger we trigger each other it's all
on purpose
i bring up your abandonment issues you
bring my perfectionist
issues up because i was watching the
special and you did this really
fresh innovative thing where you were in
different outfits
uh and it was over a couple nights and
remember i was like
do not do that i was so angry about it
we were in the comedy show parking you
are
stressed she was like i'm gonna wear a
couple different outfits and i was like
what
like i was like no what do you mean like
it made me
angry like i remember driving home being
like this is an irreconcilable
difference like we just
i couldn't understand what you were
thinking
i was just like i need to call her agent
tomorrow
i need to put a stop to this i need to
stage an intervention
and it was so fun to watch and i was
wrong
no that's first of all i you whenever
someone though
gives you feedback that's not what
you're expecting or you want that's like
the best person
to know yeah so it you when you gave us
that note
we actually like really took it in and
we considered doing the same outfit
twice like
which would have helped this is all too
like inside baseball but just know that
that note
i like respected it and took it in yeah
like almost went with it but then at the
last minute i was like wait i want to
wear this skirt
but thank you i also wasn't sure what
like she just does this really
the way you know i think that specials
now we comedians have to
evolve you know i cannot stand when
comedians are like why can't i say
tranny it's like dude
is that really what's holding you back
from writing a new joke like you ca
is that why you have writer's block like
i think comedians because we're
professional complainers that's what we
do for a living
we're obsessed with injustice um uh and
we don't love change in general we're
control freaks
you know i think we have to evolve as
viewers evolve you know there's so much
content out there you can watch a
panda bear dancing to beyonce like how
are you going to fucking compete with
youtube
now with a stand-up special you know
watching one person in the same outfit
for an hour it's now that i've seen your
special i'm like that's crazy
i can't believe we were that boring for
so long that is how i feel because
even like the best specials i've ever
seen like sometimes i have to pause them
because i'm like i have an instagram
brain like i need to just be seeing
different looking things at all times
yeah i did want to cut it up and also it
didn't hurt
to have less time for stand up and be
able to cut just
just the best stuff no i think it was
just really it felt very this is the
oldest most boomer shit i'll ever say it
just felt very
modern to me it just felt very like it
met me at my
uh level of attention deficit do you
know what i mean it didn't the best
compliment yeah i agree
like there was no work involved it
didn't feel like homework i didn't feel
like now i have to finish this special
like it was just
it felt like the experience of
going through someone's instagram feed
and like now i wanna go see about their
family and i wanna see them in a
different outfit and i want to see them
talk about something different like it
was really
incredibly um you have incredible
instincts thank you whitney
and i'm glad you didn't take my advice
on that one but you should take my
advice about everything i usually do
yeah
i usually do exactly well another thing
because we're talking about our
friendship one of my favorite things
about you
is that you just kind of go with it like
i remember last year towards the end of
the year like i had family in town i was
really stressed out and i had a set at
the comedy store
and i saw you were on the lineup in a
different room than me but at the same
time and i just texted you and i was
like
hey we're on the same time like me an
hour before and you just wrote why and i
was like
so we can hang out and then i like me
expecting you to just like not reply
you're like and then you just go okay
see you then see you in 15 minutes i'm
like like you're just down but you don't
get it but then once you like
then you're in you know it's interesting
once i'm in i'm in
yeah once i'm in i'm in i'm gonna be
honest with you that i'm always early
so i was gonna be early anyway so that
was just
good to know that was that i do have a
rule that i do no same-day plans
you don't really yes i do no same-day
plans that's a rule for me because it's
hard for me to say no
uh it's taken me a long time to be able
to say no to someone especially women
that's a whole other thing because i
grew up around
very sensitive women where if you stood
up for yourself or said you had a need
they freaked out so i just kind of like
it was like
they got emotional so i just learned do
everything on their timetable
and when someone you and chelsea pretty
do this because we're on a chain now and
you'll be like what are you guys doing
let's
go for a walk in an hour and i feel my
codependence coming up being like
jump down the fireman's pole get in the
car and like get out there to go on this
walk with them or you'll never hear from
them again
i have this thing with friendships where
i relate to that i
feel for you on that but i said but it's
really hard for me to not stick to my sk
but if i i make schedules for myself so
that i can have pride because
um cooperation and productivity make
dopamine and during this time
so much depression stuff has come up and
so much mental health stuff
that i realized i just need to really
schedule out my time
and achieve the thing i set out to
achieve or else i'll feel
listless and and sloppy and crazy
there's nothing i respect more than when
someone
sets a boundary for themself like that
it is so
valuable and important um me and my
college friends last year
we set we made this little like 2018
rule was a 22 2018 i don't remember but
it was like no flake 2019. so we set
this rule where it was like
none of us can flake on any plans for
this whole
year unless you're sick or like work
emergency whatever it is in case you
don't want to go
yeah so no no no no for real though and
if you did we it was like the honor
system with the three of us and if you
flaked
you had to do a punishment and so our
punishment was like
you know if one of us lives on the east
side the other one lives on the west
side like you have to drive across town
at rush hour to hang out at like a
coffee shop so it was like
there was doesn't sound like college
friends it sounds like a fight club
[Music]
but so we we did that for a year and it
really
taught me to not say yes to things that
i
might want to not do later i think half
the time we say yes to something it's
because we know we're going to cancel
or we're going to figure out i'll get
out of it later i'll just say yes now
and then think of an excuse later
exactly so once we implemented that i
got so much better at like
not then that was a great boundary for
me to learn like don't say yes if you're
just gonna flake
so boundaries for yourself the answer is
usually no that's my default the answer
is
usually no and it's gonna make our
relationship better like
you know and you're you're a tricky one
for me because
i don't really romantic relationships
don't um daunt me as much because i know
they're gonna end like
like romantic relationships i don't men
don't break my heart anymore that i just
i've
i have no tears left i have no tears
left for men
but female friendships i'm actually
really trepidatious with i get scared
i've actually
probably had my heart broken the most um
by women
i know what you mean it's like female
friendships are complicated and it's
like kind of our job to just like tackle
them and figure them out because you can
get so much out of them
it's so rewarding me and annie letterman
actually have this like
unspoken but also spoken rule where i'm
it goes both ways we're allowed to call
each other and leave literally 20 missed
calls on the other person's phone
and the other person who has the 20
missed calls is allowed to not call back
for two days like
there's no pressure keeping score
there's no pressure there's no
resentment
there's no uh i just did this you now
need to do this
yes it's very like i accept you where
you are
and unconditionally yeah you're allowed
to ignore me for
as long as you need to i really need to
rewire my brain around that because
growing up around a mother that was very
sensitive and very emotional i learned
that when you take care of yourself
there is a cost
and when some a woman does something
nice for you you have to reciprocate it
you have to worry about their feelings
all the time their discomfort all the
time you know some of our most stressful
relationships
are with the people that are supposed to
make us feel the least stressed out
yeah and watching your special i learned
so much more about you because i
i was always so confused about your
personality
i was like great compliment
well i just was like there's something
very paradoxical about you because
you do stand up which is ostensibly one
of the scariest things you can do i
think most people's biggest fear
yet you're the most fearful person i
know yeah and you're scared of
everything yes
and so it's an interesting paradox every
six months i ask you whitney is flying
safe
you and i are so different and that you
know
and and i i think i'm too far on the
other end of the spectrum i'm scared of
absolutely nothing
wow because number one i grew up in
extremely dangerous
circumstances all the time and number
two
i have worked really hard to realize
like i just
do not worry about things that i can't
control yeah but it's taken a long time
like
to rewire that and i look at you and i'm
like i actually should move more towards
esther like you
you're very empathic and um
i appreciate that about you and i think
sorry last thing i'll say
is that super fearful would you describe
yourself as anxious
yes super fearful super anxious people
are actually that is a huge evolutionary
advantage
a thousand years ago you would be the
most successful person in the tribe
just fyi i just think we have no way
because right now
i'm five feet tall we think reno you can
just sneak into caves and under rocks
and very easily hide you're perfect you
can't really reach for
you know lemons or oranges but you know
that someone else let someone else do
that
um no but i just think it's important to
remember as we
i think overly pathologize people who
are anxious people that are fearful
people that have quote irrational fears
you know
we were designed uh to not live in
houses with alarm systems and
locked doors and roofs right so having
anxiety actually uh was
a part of survival of the fittest the
most anxious or the most fit the most
paranoid the most hyper vigilant
so i think you evolved beautifully it's
just everything else changed so you're
just
you're living in the wrong time thank
you another great compliment
that i will just cherish but you are i
just want to say you are really good at
helping with those things because i'll
be like whitney is flying safe you're
like there's no articles about
pilots and flight attendants like being
sick from flying
yeah like and i'm like oh yeah she's so
right
and then i go and i fly off on my tour
like it's just you really
are very helpful it is my pleasure
and watching your special you have these
vignettes of you and your parents
and on this show we talk a lot about
growing up in you know dysfunctional
homes what happened with your primary
caretaker to give you certain
maladaptive behaviors i feel like the
people that listen to this show
we think a lot about you know what
happened in our childhood to make us the
uh good and the bad of what we are today
what i
we haven't really talked about on the
show is the trauma
of having parents who are still married
[Laughter]
and i think actually there's something
really
uh uh yeah i mean frankly dramatic about
that
you know everyone i know whose parents
are married i
my instinct is well your parents are
married you have no problems like that's
my brain
but that's the more immature take from
maybe a couple years ago but now i'm
kind of like oh my god like
married parents like the pressure that
must cause to say what excuse do i have
to not make a relationship work or
i don't feel that pressure that's
interesting though i definitely don't
feel that pressure like
their relationship is it's not like i'm
not one of those people that's like oh
my
romantic parents and i have such a good
example of love like
absolutely not i don't want a
relationship that's anything like theirs
they're crazy or you see
or you just but you do see people
working it out you know you do see
people
with a set crystallized definition of
what a relationship is like because i
saw so many divorces and
i grew up with single people i at least
saw people try a bunch of different
things and fail and go like oh you can
fail and it's okay
and i feel like if i grew up with
married parents i'd be like yeah they
made it work what's my excuse like even
if it's not
you know healthy it's like you figure it
out you compromise relationship is a job
like i
am always curious about what having
married parents does to your psyche
well i mean one thing is that so they're
a second marriage
okay mom's second marriage okay and so
you know that's also a play like helpful
that's yeah okay um there's been some
failure in your life that's
good there's been plenty yeah you need
people need adversity it's so
important i mean um yeah absolutely um
but so
they're uh my mom's second marriage and
they they're a big age difference
my mom is 15 years younger than my dad
so i do see how that has influenced me
because
you know there's like a something that
works about that for them
you know my dad's like old and defeated
so and she like does everything they're
just they're not a normal example it's
definitely not like
like whereas my fiance his parents i
feel like they're they're high school
sweethearts and they're still together
that i feel like that's yeah that okay
you're right that's the kind of thing
that i'm like
that is traumatic it's traumatic i just
fee and maybe this is just me doing
meaning making we've talked about
meaning making on the podcast it's
basically turning lemons into lemonade
or whatever like you always want to
figure out when something like that
negative happens to you the meaning make
it of it like what am i what's the gift
of this
what's the meaning making of this what
am i learning what am i getting out of
this failure or this
this adversity i now that i'm older and
maybe i'm just meaning making but
i'm so glad the shoe dropped early
yeah otherwise you're constantly waiting
for the shoe to drop yeah
you know the damocles sword is hung like
i'm just i'm i'm now
as i'm as an adult there's sort of a
relief that's like
okay my dad already died my mom already
had a stroke like all these bad things
already happened like what's the worst
that could happen
right chronovirus comes i'm like okay
fine let's handle this like nothing
i think there is something that's a safe
place in later in life after you've had
enough
tragedy in your life um nothing you know
you're like the worst is kind of behind
me there's something that's kind of a
relief about that
yeah no that's cool i i feel like i i
s that's i like that living by that
whereas whereas your
your fiance is an anxious mess because
his life has been too good
like the worst is in front of him i'd be
stressed out too i know well
i feel like you'll relate to this the
first time i met his parents we all went
out to a nice dinner
and dave was like cracking jokes and his
parents
were just like laughing at everything
they were saying and i remember sitting
there like
staring like what's going on i didn't
know that your own parents
could find you funny it was so
weird i just like was physically like
funny where am i
like it was so weird the healthiness and
the love
yeah yeah yeah which is you know i'm now
that you've seen my special you probably
can see why i felt that way and i'm sure
you probably had a similar thing
because you don't seem normal i have a
hot take i'm on your parents side
uh well my mom thinks you're her
daughter
so you know what's so weird when i was
watching your special i didn't even put
together that you're my
your mom and i are very close yeah would
you is that whatever you would call it
she consumes everything you put out
she updates me on your story she watches
everything my dad
i'm pretty sure my dad hates you
because my mom is always doing something
about you
that's so weird he hates all my like so
that's my demo twice married older women
with comedian daughters
so i i do i think i'm just in a place
you guys have heard me talk about this
on the back i am just in a place of
radical forgiveness
with parents because they simply did not
have the tools
you know and i think we talk about this
a lot of we forgive others not because
they deserve forgiveness but because we
deserve peace
and it's just sort of like i can blame
my parents all day long i
certainly can do that but it sort of
like hasn't worked that great
and so i'm just going to radically
forgive them because they didn't they
didn't get what they needed either
yeah i know i totally agree with you and
i i it's
i love to like publicly be like it's my
parents fault you know like they locked
me in a gate and i cried
but it's they were doing what they could
that was it was kind of amazing there's
this part where
uh esther's one of her teachers locked
her like in a closet and her dad's like
how come we didn't do that like it's
just so like
it also i i maybe i have stockholm
syndrome and i'm kind of like yeah like
it's only in the last like 10 years that
we started thinking children
should be protected from anything i mean
it is a very new
we used to it's just so we kids used to
work in factories like no
it's very new yeah that we think
children
are valuable on any level yes you know
it's weird
yeah you know so i feel i just watched
your dad and i was like yeah i feel like
in his day that's actually a pretty good
name humane closets are safe
yeah you know there's no one you know
they're safe in there no one's gonna get
in there they can take a nap like it's
everything's soft it's all closed
like you know like i sort of i
i appreciated that but i also saw
where you got you know your wit and and
i think that a lot of becoming funny
is having to defend yourself as a kid
like full stop
you know like people are always like oh
my god having the name coming he's like
that must be a nightmare i'm like yeah
but it also
made me have to i got bullied so much as
a kid about it that i had to get quick
and i had to learn how to throw insults
back that has to be a huge reason why
you're comedian do you feel like that i
think so
yeah i think so i think i think in terms
of having to defend myself and having to
i think a lot of comedians
you know who was it that said the
definition of uh or stand up comedy
we do it so that um
we can uh insult ourselves
we can control the way we're embarrassed
yeah we embarrass ourselves before you
can do it
that is so correct i always say like i
can't be embarrassed like i
no i will be i know i'm gonna be
embarrassed here let me just let me
handle it so that you guys don't do it
and ambush me or
sidetrack like i to know and control how
i'm going to be embarrassed
so relatable i really love that i kind
of feel
like you've gotten a little bit fucked
over in a way
where you were like the feminist kind of
before
feminism was like cool and
you were the star the creator
and star of an nbc sitcom and people
made fun of you online yeah and that's
kind of like
the worst fear yeah and you've come from
that you've come through that
i was cancelled before cancer culture
even happened but you were like
but it was like not for doing something
wrong people
made fun of you and that was really
fucked up and i it was sexism
that was like pure i mean there was if
you
go back at the reviews of the nbc show i
did
it's there's comments literally about my
appearance
i mean there's literally of like she's
fucking she's wiry she's willowy
like i mean it's they're they're talking
about my appearance
in the reviews that uh a couple reviews
call me shrill
like it is so wild it's really like you
really went through that and
i feel like i don't know i feel like you
got it the like almost like the worst
like you were like i'm a fucking woman
i'm a creator i'm funny
and then literally reviewers berated
your women female viewers as well i mean
emily nussbaum
just going for it i mean her review was
wild
like just mean and i and i think i look
back now and i'm like i think i i
i as someone that goes for always for
forgiveness if i can't i went through
all the pain of that i went through the
embarrassment and the shame and the
sadness
kind of later i i had a little delay
of processing it i think that i i
blocked it out kind of when it was
happening because it was number one
my mom had just had a stroke i had
another family member who was super sick
my dad had a stroke
the universe kind of colluded to
distract me from that with like
other tragedies that put everything in
perspective about like a bad review
you know um but i you know
i look back at that and i was like god i
guess i
really trigger people i feel like we've
said that word a lot on the podcast like
i understand like
a loud woman but you know that that
doesn't want to get married that's what
the show is about it was about
it was of gender reversal i wanted to do
a very traditional
classic sitcom where the man had the
qualities of stereotypical woman and the
woman had the
qualities of a man no i remember i
watched the show i
did watch it illegally because i didn't
have cable that was like back when i
knew how to watch shows illegally
i watched every episode i thought it was
so funny and awesome
and it actually really sucked like not
to make this about me but
i'm not gonna like it suck that i looked
up to this person and watched your show
and then saw like all these
shitty people yeah making fun of it and
i didn't know why
yeah and i just feel like how do you get
through like i'm like how could anyone
survive that but then here you are like
literally thriving
created a successful show like you've
done so much since and
i just want to like acknowledge that
that was fucked up
and it's weird and it doesn't like there
needs to be like a renaissance about it
like wait we all need to apologize
that was wild that's so interesting that
you're bringing this up and i'm sorry
like i feel like it could be even
triggering to bring up and like no i'm
so glad no i'm so glad you're
it's not something i can bring up but as
i look back like
if you were please rehash these reviews
you know i think for me you know i
know why a lot of people didn't like it
because it was on
nbc and it was a multicam and this is
getting into the granular of the
different
tv shows anyone listening knows the
difference between a multicam and a
single camera
multicam seinfeld friends
audience big there's a live studio
audience right and then a single cam is
like the office parks and rec community
i was in the block of parks and rec
community
the office and then a multicam show
you know where there's like a live
studio audience like it was just like
all the comedy nerds
right weren't gonna watching these shows
that were more like subtle performances
and
way drier like that was starting to
become a little more in vogue
you know a little um uh the lighting is
bleaker and drab like the office was
obviously you know really popular 30
rock like that those are single camera
shows
the show should have been on like cbs
yeah you know
with like mike and molly two and a half
men like like big bang theory multicams
like it would have i think fit better
yeah but there was a very malicious um
energy that that came at me like people
would say like it's a laugh track
i would even say to the journalists i
was like do you want to come see the
people in the audience like it's like
you know we had to take microphones out
of the audience like no one
wanted uh to like it you know
it was it was i mean even writers like
big
big writers who one one of whom has
since apologized to me
i think it was like a year ago i mean
hollywood writers
would like tweet like really malicious
shit about it
um which that doesn't happen right now
like people don't do that you can't do
that
like if uh if uh if if a tv show with
um starring a woman came out no one
could just tweet about it and trash it
fuck her she's whatever no one could you
could not do that
you know and uh one of them recently
apologized to me actually
it was actually really well because a
lot of people i looked up to and really
admired and liked
um uh trashed me like on twitter
like as if i like wouldn't see it or
something
and um one of them apologized to me
recently and was like uh
yeah i was you know and this is what he
said so it is what it is but he was like
i was just so jealous
that you got something at 27 years old
and you had this show and it also got
it was ubiquitous it also got because
plot twist i test very well
you have to understand that if a show
gets a lot of promotion it means it did
well in the testing
right and crystallia was on the show he
was fucking hysterical and we had great
chemistry which is kind of the whole
sort of like and that tested very highly
so they ended up giving us
a lot of promotion and anyone that's
like
all over fucking the sides of buildings
i i feel like if
i was a comic and saw a show that was
called like amanda and it was like a
like a girl that was like holding a
beach ball sassy i would probably make
fun of it too
you know like but but i feel like we're
learning and i hope everyone is on board
with this that like
not everything is for you so if
you see amanda in the beach ball like
maybe it's not for you
but it's for someone yeah and you're
like yucking someone's young yeah and
i just think it's i don't know i just
don't wanna
i get it we all wanna make fun of stuff
it's fun but i do think a weird
very like i feel like very
sexist reaction filled with jealousy
happened to you and like you come
through it you didn't like
quit the business and like move to
wichita yeah that's impressive to me i
never really
it's weird i don't think i've ever
gotten over it you know i think it was
it was a kind of
trauma a kind of emotional trauma where
i feel like i
i which is also weird because the show
does really well in other countries like
people
also like love it i can't stress this
enough watched every episode
i'm waiting for it to like come out
somewhere it's not
the peacock oh it is it just came on the
peacock okay streamer
i need to get peacock yeah people like
it's weird people do love it because
i really wanted to make a show god so it
was long ago but
that was uh universal you know like so
many
i mean literally we shot at universal
but uh uh there were a lot of shows on
about very specific like i loved the
office but it was about a very specific
american sense of humor you know they
had their
their award thing at chili's you know
it's sort of like everything with
specific american comedy community
very specific i want to do something
that was like if you don't
even if this could air in any country
it's about like
why did your ex just text you anyone any
culture any cree
anyone in any part of the world can
relate to that fight that is a universal
fight that transcends
i think culture religion so many things
you know and i
really wanted to make that show about
little tiny things like there was an
episode
i fucking love this episode where uh the
uh my boyfriend character
shushes me and that's it that's the
whole up that's the whole that's the
beginning of the whole episode
it's just and that exactly
whereas so many shows now we're like and
he's dead the whole time
and it's secretly a vampire like
everything's so
fucking complicated whereas the reality
is the most of our
real estate com and that's taken up
is like why are you having lunch with
your ex like that's what most of us have
to do that sounds fucking interesting
that to me is is an episode i mean there
was an episode with june rayfield
who played the x which was why do you
have a box of your ex's stuff it was
like a box of her stuff
you know someone that has that that yeah
that's
i know that that's real i love that shit
like that's the kind of shit i love
like there was a whole episode about you
know we've talked about it on this show
of um
i wash my boyfriend's jeans and he gets
really upset
because you're not supposed to wash
jeans guys don't wash their jeans
it's weird dave never lets me wash his
pants no you're not allowed to wash
guys don't wash their jeans it's weird i
need to just override yeah that's
why we have a coronavirus i'm telling
you i that is the real origin of it
but yeah no i i the last thing i want to
say about whitney even though i just cut
you off and it's your show no
please is the episode where you like
accidentally blurt out
the phrase uber cray-cray do you know
what i'm talking about
um i blurted it out okay yes uber
cray-cray yes
it's so stupid and so funny and i say it
all the time
still eight years later it's so good
it's so
weird i should have known there that you
were so weird
but i just want to like give that show
like a
solid shout out and moment that it is so
good yeah and that it like blows my mind
that
more people aren't like wait we like
were fucked up about this thing and it
was a woman getting her shot
and we like ruined it a little bit i
mean they didn't ruin it because you
made so many episodes
of it but like well that's the other
thing i think we made we made two
seasons and i remember this because like
i would have
journalists interview me and now i look
back and i'm like oh my god they were
being so shitty to me and i was
too naive and young to know i assumed if
a journalist was interviewing you for an
article like they liked you
uh-huh like that's such a i like they
were just gonna write you the way you
meant to sound
like they would write me as the person i
am which is
you know or something and they don't
have vendettas or agendas or
you know there was this guy um i can't
even remember his fucking name but
he got fired over the interview um what
because
what's david goldman i think his name is
can you google uh
i don't give a fuck uh he interviewed
like literally i remember waking up like
6 a.m and he's like hey
i've never heard of you but my wife
really likes you and i remember being
like
okay like i just was like still
programmed to laugh at and
right you're like any joke a man says
i'm like oh
like you don't know me i'm just going to
try harder to get your approval
and he said something he's like he said
something about me like he was like on
the roast someone made a joke about you
sleeping your way to the top is that
true
yeah that's true here's all the guys i
fucked yeah like cause yeah
guys just like print scripts that need
to be shot
like as if that's ever worked david
goldman he was at the new yorker
i think i've learned that if someone is
interviewing them it's
like i need to kind of get clarity on
what the article is about because i
recently did an interview and they made
the article kind of about what they
wanted it to be about
and not about what made sense for me so
i will just say that that's a real thing
andrew goldman um i was just
filling time while you were looking that
up thank you thank you
um this bitch holds a grudge
and yeah i just i had no idea that
someone would want to
embarrass someone else or you know i i
just i don't think i realized like
female comics are the most hated people
on the planet a little bit
we are hated you know and that
and anyone listening to this show
listening to female comics talk
obviously you're not
you know but we are very triggering to
people
and there is um and i don't know if it's
because there's a subconscious like
they're signing up to be rejected like
they're putting themselves out there to
be critiqued or whatever but there is a
very real vitriol
around a woman that is fucking speaking
for an
hour and no one else gets to interrupt i
mean there is a like a fucking who do
you think you are i need to tear you
down to size yeah i feel like that's
what was happening to me
yeah i feel like when i did a sitcom and
had a
i had two shows at once two broke girl
this is when you had to be apologetic
and small and minimize yourself and if
you were
successful you were like you know uh
i think there was a how dare you who do
you think you are
and you don't deserve it you don't get
to win like this yeah
not on my watch yeah and everyone
decided they were going to make a
sort of um like a salem witch truck it
felt very much like a
we need to make an example out of her
that that's how
women too by the way i'm this is not i
know this is like women
fucking came for me and you know it's
it's
it's tricky and i i do think i sort of
learned to sort of go numb a little bit
about that because i was just like okay
like
the price of what i do is there's gonna
be a lot of people that are gonna have
some irrational hate
for me and that's just part of this like
i get to pay my bills and i get to have
health insurance like that's just the
price i pay like i sort of that's how
the meaning making of how i've
kind of rationalized it that's
unfortunate i wasn't taught you could
have it all
like this next generation yeah no they
could have it all i never thank god
i was drilled into my head by my dad
life is not fair
so i didn't think i deserved more i was
like okay well
if my bills are getting paid like you
know this is a small price to pay
but you know there is a i think it's
interesting for us to all look at our
internalized misogyny
about a woman you know how triggering it
is when women
get successful i do it too i have it too
i haven't have it
i have it i have it i guess like i'm
furious about your special that it's so
good
like frankly i hope there's a campaign
to tear you down
and um you know but you know it is
interesting but there's also
there's almost like an immersion therapy
is that what it's called exposure
therapy of like social therapy
how my worst nightmare is having people
hate me
and yeah and it just happens that's why
i'm so interested
like what am i gonna do there's not
there's a certain freedom
in having everyone uh
uh having that which by the way twitter
is not everyone that's the other thing
twitter is not everyone the majority of
like america really liked it and thought
it was good
like this was just on twitter we have to
remember twitter is not real life
twenty percent of people are on twitter
of that two percent
generate eighty percent of the comments
like i need to repeat that statistic to
myself a lot really like when you say
that
yeah i say it a lot i really love it i'm
a broken record with that one
um and it was kind of as someone who was
so
programmed to be loved that's all i ever
wanted was for people to like me
for people to love me uh to contort
shape-shift
to try to make people laugh and having
this sort of
mass uh backlash
that kind of couldn't have been worse
yeah right like it kind of couldn't be
and i don't even know
all of it because i was no i don't you
know i don't have anything you don't i
i didn't no i remember i was working on
the show and again my mom had a stroke
so i wasn't googling myself i wasn't on
twitter like i was like in an icu
writing the first season of that show
and i remember going to like an mvc
party like for upfront
like the first thing i like went out to
do that was like i'm promoting a show
and i like
put on a dress that like like an old
dress from like delia's or something
like i didn't have like stylists like i
didn't have any you know
it was before i had like the checks had
started clearing or anything
and i went to a public space and
everyone was coming up to me like how
you doing
you okay you hanging in there like
people would
everyone like as if i had like a
terminal illness people like they're
just jealous
don't you you know everyone hated
seinfeld the first season like people
were just consoling me
and i didn't know what they were talking
about i thought they were talking about
the fact that my mom had just had a
stroke and i was like oh she's gonna be
okay and they're like what
like i didn't know about it i think
thankfully
yeah um but yeah i i do think um
it left a mark uh in a way that
has definitely made me i think i'm a
pretty reclusive person
and i um you know
always assume people are talking shit
about me
which is part of the reason i have a lot
of distrust yeah
for other i feel i assume everyone's
being fake with me and disingenuous
because that was a time where everyone
was being nice to my face but i feel
like shitting on me behind my back
yeah and you know during the whole
you know crystalia nightmare as of
recently
just so all y'all i know everyone who's
tried to say i knew
i know your names and i just want you to
know
that the people that you think you're
confiding in
they're more loyal to me than you fyi
well it is isn't that that's like
another like weird public reaction that
or like whatever it is public shaming
kind of reaction where it's like
they knew that person knew but it's like
how why are you
you don't know that you're just like
creating drama because it's fun
can i ask you a question about this like
i think that people that are in male
dominated businesses women especially
like
you know number one men don't show us
their untoward behavior
you know but at the same time i do think
we see a side of men
that is slightly discouraging i think
it's taken me a long time
to realize like you know because all my
friends are male comics
and then when i'm with someone who's not
a male comic i'm like
so how many porn stars do you follow and
they're like what why did i follow porn
stars and i'm like oh
like my bar's on the floor do you think
that
being in a toxic environment has
affected the way that you
view yeah then like has it done a number
well i wouldn't say it's done a number
or women frankly but i will say like
it's been interesting having close
relationships with
men over the years close friendships and
you do
like end up talking about dating and
stuff and i
like just feel like i know certain
things that the way guys see girls and
it's
kind of upsetting but it's also like
similar to like oh well at least now i
know
you know okay yeah so now i know that
whatever
you guys think this about us yeah
whatever it is and i kind of try to use
it in my tool kit as like a strength
yeah but but i know what you mean and it
is
yeah we like see guys hitting on girls
all the time but
that also it doesn't mean that like
we're the truth is and this is almost
gonna sound
like i'm i don't know how this is going
to sound but like
we're like no we're not like you're not
in the club like we're not
in the club like i know people think we
are we are in we are in a club
yeah but like the cool guys they're
awesome and i love them
but there's a certain way that they're
never going to see me
and there's a certain way that they're
never going to see other people
uh people of color gay people are like
they're never going to be equal with
like the top
tier white men yeah like you don't know
their secrets i don't know their secrets
and that's i don't know i feel like
maybe i'm saying miss speaking and
saying wrong shit but
that's just kind of how i feel like i
know i'm very lucky and i've been
accepted in many ways
because of my like white privilege and
yeah i'll say it i'm gorgeous
but like i'm just kind of saying that
like for the people that maybe think
that like you're best friends with these
people and they tell you their secrets
like they don't
yeah and you're not i think it's
interesting because as we were talking
earlier i'm just fascinated by this and
i'm never gonna stop talking to you
um is that this this superficial
sense of closeness you know is like just
because sort of
you and i becoming close recently has
become very real
and i think that you know sometimes we
get these trauma bonds with people and
these like artif i think it's happening
a lot
you know like don't mistake a trauma
bond for love
yeah i don't love that yeah i i've seen
that happen yeah
yeah don't mistake love and pity don't
mistake you know
having a rough day with someone else on
the job as like you guys
shouldn't are friends or close like
we've kind of talked about that and i
think that's a lot of
what our you know relationships are like
with uh
other comedians you know is that like we
know each other really well because we
have the same job but i don't know
anything about
it right i don't know what you do when
you wake up and you kind of have to be
nice to me
like i realized that recently i was just
sort of like everybody's so nice to me
because after sort of this um a lot of
stuff has been coming to light in the
comedy community a lot of people
sort of are like how could you not know
all this and i'm like i guess people
pretend in front of me it's like benton
was like you realize you never see how
these people actually act
right like they act totally different in
front of you and there's something kind
of
weird about realizing that um
it's hard to it's hard to
come to terms with the fact that people
have secrets and i think
you know anyone that listening is
listening to this podcast is committed
to
edifying themselves in some way but not
everyone else
is like not everyone is doing the work
we're doing not everyone is
on a daily basis going like how can i be
better like how can i be more honest how
can i be
you know more authentic how can i you
know
be less jealous how can i be you know
like most people yeah
a lot of people are just going through
life unconscious like zombies just sort
of getting their primal carnal needs met
like
you know and i think that that i feel
really grateful that i have people in my
life that are like really consciously
trying to deprogram but i think they're
shit
a lot of people just are not yeah and
that's so hard for me to believe
and that's such a fucked up like every
time i meet someone i just assume
like they've read every self-help book
i've read
and i've been to therapy for 10 years
they're only going to 12-step program
you know and i'm just sort of like did
you just lie to me
like it's so when someone lies i mean
lie still yeah like what
like that i thought we all stopped lying
is like the slap bracelet
of you know character defects like
that's so 90s like who lies like i used
to lie
so much and it's just like it's a
full-time
job lying you have to like de-program
numbers to be organized you have to be
so organized you have to remember your
lines you have to be off book
like lying is like exhausting
so and i also know now that like when
you lie you
feel worse yeah you know yeah and it's
right we're only as sick as the secrets
we keep so it's like then you feel
shame and then when you lie to someone
this is the most fucked up part about
lying
you lose respect for them yeah because
you're like you believed that a lot
oh you're such a fucking like dumbass
like how did i how did i just pull that
off
and then you lose respect for them you
know
i one of my favorite things to do is to
admit that you lied
like in when you just said you respected
the way i dress and then you're like
i lied i love just like admitting that
you just lied like
i that is there's something cute about
it it's so
funny when you catch yourself lying and
you're like what was that i'm sorry like
he does that a lot dave does that all
the time i'll ask him something and
he'll answer and i'm like
you made that up and don't know he's
like yeah you're right
i hate this i trust you went to harvard
i trust you
or like yeah when i i've catch myself
making up fake statistics a lot too
i'll just be like look 80 of people are
never enough
and benjamin will be like where what
where did you what what
pole was that i'm like i don't know it
just like felt right like it just felt
but no i was um uh i was with my lover
and i have these ducks that keep landing
in the pool and i saw the ducks like
earlier in the day and
he was in the kitchen it was like six
and i'd seen the ducks at like noon
and he was in the kitchen and i was like
oh the ducks were just outside
and he was like oh i just let the dogs
out should i bring him back in and i was
like
well i mean i actually saw him at like
noon but i just i just wanted
i i just wanted you to think they were
just there yeah like i don't know it was
such a weird lie
toddler i know like what he was just
like
so the ducks weren't just there and i
was like i guess i was trying to impress
you like i don't know what that was
like that was so weird like i just
wanted you to think i had ducks like
just
like it was just such an like when you
catch yourself doing like
codependent people please yeah and
you're like oh that was gross but it's
cool to be self-aware
and like try to just be better
taking a little break here to talk about
italic
i'm not going to look at the copy like
these other podcasters that you
listen to that just half-heartedly
read like robots i would like to
tell you about italic you can tell
they're reading it for the first time
you know a lot about robots too i do
know a lot about robots having been one
for 37 years
but italic i'm obsessed with this
company and if you're listening on audio
and not on youtube you're really missing
out because i'm holding up
this bag that i got from italic how
pretty is this it's like a
it's almost like an oxblood color is
that what you would call it they're
really nice quality
goods i mean i have a backpack that i
got from them oh nice
stunning what does it look like it's
like a a leather
and it's black and it has like these
gold almost like this purse with a
backpack
like this person like and the whole deal
with italics is
they you don't have to pay for their
advertising like will you read the copy
because we do need to explain we have to
explain what the product is at some
point
but you are paying sane prices i
i refuse to pay five thousand dollars
for a person you know me i don't i won't
do it you won't attack is how
i fake it till i make it yeah but you've
seen my closet how many purses do i have
three like truly i will not buy new
purses because they're all for some
reason like
seven thousand dollars i shall not chant
italic is a membership that grants
access to over 800 plus
quality goods made by the same
manufacturers as top brands
but sold at cost meaning you're not
paying to put the little
symbols on it that you sheeple
they're 60 lower prices than leading
brands
they basically cut out them wait hold on
you're blowing past the the
60 percent lower prices you should blow
past that number
i mean i'm just reading the coffee it's
over half
it's the same product but 60 percent
cheaper
what are we doing why would you ever buy
non-italic products listen you know me
nothing i hate more than being scammed
then you know that i hate more than a
racquet and everything is a racket
except for italic excuse me i need to
now finish putting the strap on my
beautiful new
purse that you're gonna use because you
got one i know i'm so into this
they have lots of stuff for both men and
women from luxury handbags
cashmere sweaters activewear bedding
bath towels cookware
and i need cookware jewelry i need the
cookware the diamond jewelry and i need
the diamond jewelry let's be honest from
the best possible manufacturers in each
category be smart don't pay a thousand
dollars for just a logo
don't be sheeple and save your money for
more important things
look how cute if you're watching on
youtube look at my cute new purse and if
you're not watching on youtube
it's cute there's currently a wait list
to join italic but they're offering but
they're offering
our listeners to skip the weight and
join immediately when you sign up
through this link italic.com
whitney sign up for the membership now
and get access to all of italics high
quality beautifully designed products to
improve your closet home kitchen and
more
and never pay for markups again wait
hold on keep this in do not cut this out
sheets from the same manufacturer as
saint regis and the four seasons why
don't i have that
leather bags by the same manufacturer as
celine and prada and even a candle from
the same scent supplier as la lava which
is my favorite candle
maker and it's like 160 bucks yeah
will you get me that we sure will we'll
sign up now
okay italic.com whitney italic.com
whitney if you're not listening on
youtube watch on youtube to see how cute
this purse is that i got from italic
because i'm
not a huckster taylor tomlinson and i
are writing something together so i'm in
full writing mode so i've been ordering
from doordash truly twice a day
yeah a lot two of my best friends uh
work for doordash currently
um one of the delivery people just got a
blue german shepherd dog half blue pit
half german shepherd i've seen pictures
that's how often i'm ordering from
doordash i know the delivery people
i am obsessed because they have they
have
every restaurant that i like i don't
know if that's like they're targeting me
or something or if they just have the
best restaurant yeah i think they built
the ad just for you actually the whole
app was built
for me and mine i knew it i knew this
was custom designed for me
um i also love doordash and we'll get
into the actual logistics about doordash
in a second these are just my initial
thoughts from actually using the product
i also love that
when it updates you on your order being
made and delivered it's always exactly
right
if your order's eight minutes away it's
seven minutes away instead of saying
eight minutes away
and it's another hour and that's my
childhood all over again they're not
joking that's me not being picked up
from school by my dad it's like they
tell you when it's coming they tell you
when it's ordered
i've not had one like rigmarole moment
with like where's my
person and where's the food and this is
the wrong food i have never from
doordash not gotten exactly what i
ordered like
before doordash i feel like you would
get like half of what you ordered
this is close enough with it was like it
was like getting cable installed it was
like a four-hour window like you might
get your food like thrown over the fence
at some point you know like it's
true all wet for no reason like doordash
they they keep it tight they keep they
run a tight ship
yeah i ordered two steaks and they got
here prestigious by the way
i did i look over there and i'm like
benton what did you order from doordash
you just went two steaks
so also no one is judgmental here at
doordash
they don't assume your order uh was a
mistake if you order something crazy
they're not like
you sure did you mean yeah they're not
google
many of your favorite local restaurants
are still open for
delivery open the door dash app select
your favorite local restaurant and your
food will be left at your door
safely it's a crazy time for restaurants
right now obviously struggling for
business so it's also a good thing to do
to order
safely from your local restaurants
doordash deliveries are now contactless
they keep communities we operate in safe
but also by the way they don't leave
them in some crazy place
they don't leave them in some like birds
nest or tree they leave it right where
you can actually see it yeah
they take a picture they show it to you
yeah it's a whole thing it's not like
they just sort of generally throw it in
your direction it's like in the bushes
yeah right now our listeners can get
five dollars off their first order of 15
or more zero delivery fees for their
first month when you download the
doordash app enter the code whitney by
the way this isn't in the copy but it's
also not just
restaurants it's like it's it's like um
coffees uh places and starbucks places
and i don't know coffee places and
starbucks places
multiple cafes can you believe i'm just
saying you can like order
you know if you get thirsty they'll also
bring you drinks they do you can just
order like a round of coffee like i just
think we had eaten so much and we were
just like we just want like a
coffee refresh and we ordered three
coffees from a coffee place
with a couple little pastries and scones
it was like such a i don't know
that's five dollars off your first order
and zero delivery fees for a month
when you download the doordash app in
the app store enter the code whitney
don't forget that's code whitney for
five dollars off your first order with
doordash doordash and such a great
alliteration doordash
doordash and so how did you when you and
i
when you started in the comedy store i
think i don't i wasn't there
all the time like i i you were very in
and out
you were on your path yeah like i was
and and
by that time i just had learn in a very
male dominated business to just get in
and do my thing and get out so i didn't
get accused of dating
or sleeping my way to whatever i had you
know i just realized the only way to not
get accused
of sleeping with people for jobs is to
just be gone
well yeah and also like sometimes you
just exist
in a male-dominated space and then it's
like you're just standing there and
someone's like they're flirting
i always feel like i was just standing i
know i and and i think there's something
really interesting about
about you because you're a little after
me right
yeah and my sort of generation of female
comics
it was very um competitive
not because i think you have to be
competitive to be a female comic you
have to sort of have a
you know um that hustle that kind of
hustle you have to have that warrior
spirit
but there was such a scarcity complex
because there were so few spots
yeah you know that even if we liked each
other we still
had to compete with each other because
it was sort of the way they used to put
comedians on lineups was like oh we have
our female we're good
one girl one girl yeah out of maybe 30
comics right which is so shitty and i do
feel like it did get it got
like better and better as time went on
so it's like i know how it was for me
and i know it must have been worse for
you
yeah and it was like it was just like
one girl that was it and so we were all
kind of vying for that one spot so it
was always so tragic to me that like in
any anyone listening that's in you know
a male dominated business like
the way you're kind of like forced to
compete with people that you actually
are the only people you really have
anything in common with yeah
we should be so we're probably soul
mates yeah we're being forced to kind of
hate each other
and uh and then you know
i feel like as you know time went on
when there was even more spots there
became more comedian so that scarcity
complex
um uh continued also this is something
that happens from women too i'm not men
don't only do this but both men and
women i think in positions of power
also pit women against each other in a
way that for them might even be
subconscious
but when i would come in the comedy
store any comedy club would be like
so and so this female comic came in she
wasn't very good
and i'm like why didn't you tell me if a
male comic didn't do well
like why oh like it's just this subtle
pitting women against each other that i
didn't fully understand until later
like so and so this girl has to go ahead
of you or this
person wants to change or she's running
late and you know she probably just
wants to make sure she goes after you so
that you're ahead of her like
just little things where i felt like the
men or women in power the fucking old
people quite frankly
uh would sort of get off on thinking or
they already had in their head that
women are catty and don't like each
other because that's everyone's that's
everyone's kind of baseline
idea i forgot about that you're right
it's like oh women are yeah
exactly women are catty you know how
they are you know how they are like you
guys all hate each other right so it was
like i was already walking into that
paradigm
and that's a really great way to control
people is to divide them
you know and i think that the kind of
people that work in our business are
fucking adrenaline drama addicts anyway
and like
fucking you know present
here and they'd pit us against each
other
in a way that i now feel like when
female comics or friends or any women in
male dominated businesses are friends
it's kind of an act of resistance you
know
and i think they don't like it you know
when i'm like talking to a female comic
in you know uh one of the comedy clubs
and people walk by they're like what are
they up to
like it's collusion i know like they're
casting a little coven over there
like so i do think that there you know
is a fear of women
getting close because if we actually
just you know
like we're able to be in a situation
conducive to getting along
you know uh you know really good things
could happen but i feel like there's so
many forces at play keeping us
yeah like not liking each other i agree
and i i'm like
i'm here for the change that we're like
experiencing
and seeing and like it's also funny that
whenever i have a female comedian on the
show people like you're so supportive of
women this is amazing like
no she's my friend like i'm not
supporting women right now like i'm
having a funny person on that i
genuinely like who's special is great
like this isn't like an act of
charity like there's also that you get
like no it is
but you get like i feel like i won a
contest
that's definitely my vibe right now you
gave me this hoodie
you got the golden ticket this hoodie
i'm like literally like this to it i am
so happy i call my parents on the way
here they're like we can't believe it
you won
also tell me about your engagement how
long has it been oh my god
why i have questions i have so many
questions for you because
i think it is so interesting that you've
been in such a long relationship i agree
i look at someone who's been in a long
relationship
like a fucking um remember those things
oh copies
half giraffe half zebras
you guys remember that animal it was
called an okapi it was like a remix of
two wild animals this is the only this
is the thing that you're the only one in
the room who knows it
for sure i look up okapi it's an okapi
it's like a like a centaur kind of
i look at people that are in long
relationships and i just like i it's
like going to the zoo like i can't tell
you how
amazed fascinated humbled i
am by it i just i'm fascinated by people
that can just be around
other people all the time no so you're
wrong or not
especially in the pandemic we are that i
think we're lucky that we've been
together for so long
that in the pandemic we can kind of just
be like see ya
yeah like we are for a while he wasn't
he wasn't
like in a writer's room so he was able
to just stay up all night so we were on
completely opposite sleep schedules
uh-huh so there's like a comfort there
that there's not a neediness anymore
and we just we do our own thing how did
you know you were in love
i mean i was in love with dave the
second i saw him really no
joke with the second i did you meet
through chelsea pretty
no we didn't we that was like afterwards
where i realized they knew each other
we i met him at a party i saw him at a
party i was there with lauren greenberg
the best greatest person ever um by the
way lauren greenberg if i have not told
you this story
lauren greenberg now runs the james
corden she's the head writer at james
gordon
i and i used to sit with her at her we
used to go to her ex-boyfriend's
apartment because there was air
conditioning so we would sit there
because of the air conditioning
and she would hand me her phone and i
would answer the calls of debt
collectors for her yeah and she'd be
like lauren this
past sorry she's passed
and that was all like before you hired
her and now she's
like running one of the most popular
shows on tv this is just i think a
really quick um as romney said last week
he went this is a tangent even for a
podcast
i mean but podcast is just one giant
tangent but for anyone who is sort of
starting out in any field
lauren greenberg um i think kevin
christie maybe turned on me onto her i
was writing shows
and i was hiring all these people that
had you know tons of credits that had
written on these huge shows like frasier
and friends and mad about you and all
the shows that i grew up loving
and i realized that sometimes when you
hire incredibly experienced people
um they uh
um what's the word they don't care about
you
you're beneath them give a shit they
don't like you yeah they
frankly don't like you that's maybe a
better way to put it i think there's
something to be said
for a young girl person who's never
written on a show
almost being more valuable than someone
that's been doing it for 30 years who's
written on every show because it's just
sort of like
there's not an excitement there's not an
alacrity about doing it there's just
sort of
not a a a grit that i think is so
essential
through writing shows there's not a
dismissiveness of like oh that's not
gonna work it's like well that just
shuts down your creativity you know
yeah and so that's why i'm so people
have this like eye roll thing about
young millennials now like they're so
like needy and annoying and whatever the
stereotype is i completely disagree like
young people if you just get your ego
out of the way
like they can teach you so much so i
just like young people who
haven't already been programmed to think
a certain way
yeah you know it's like when you hook up
with a guy who's been in a long
relationship and he goes down on you and
like does something like super specific
and you're like
okay i now know exactly how your
ex has an orgasm i know
so much about her but let's just regroup
she's like and you're like okay all
right like
copy that i know her inside and out
but we're gonna have to start over
female body they're like snowflakes
everyone is different so the same thing
kind of happens in any chat
in any job you know so someone
recommended me this girl lauren
greenberg
she had hilarious tweets and i called
her in
and she right she was very nervous
she was incredibly nervous in the
meaning which i see i
love that i loved it i hate it when
people pretend they're something they're
not and then you have to enter into some
shitty
like bad long-form improv with them
you know what i'm saying i like it when
someone's just like i'm really nervous
this is very overwhelming i'm like great
this is a person that tells the fucking
truth i already love you
yeah you're already not pretending you
can like
are doing something or i know you're not
going to lie to me moving forward you
know
there's nothing worse than someone's
like i got that and they have no idea
how to do it
and by the way i always believe that
person i'm like oh they got it
they said they got it i'm following them
i'm like no no no never goes well the
person who always says i know
i got it no problem that person is like
a fucking mess
and nothing's gonna get done right i
like the person that's like i don't know
how to do this could someone teach me
and i'm like i can trust you
i know that you're gonna get the
solution instead of pretend you know
something you don't
yeah so lauren comes in she's nervous
she's like i'm really nervous i'm like i
already love you
we start talking i guess her mom had put
her on a dating app without telling her
yeah lauren is a funny like her story is
wild and she was working at a company
that measures your food ahead of time
for you like with scoops
yeah likes pre-measured scoopers so that
you could like
like ascertain how many calories you're
about to eat anyway we start talking
she's
she's like shy and nervous i can tell
which is what uh how i was
in the beginning and then she just like
started crying
no way i swear to god lauren no and i
was like
uh and i knew i was gonna give her the
job and i'm such a dick that i was like
oh shit tell her should i wait oh i'm
gonna wait i'm gonna make her sweat it
out
yeah then i was like i'm gonna make her
sweat it out and then uh because i don't
you have to like run it by like hr
before you officially hire someone right
and uh especially if they're crying
yeah she wasn't crying and to me i think
most people would leave that meeting
going
i cried in a meeting i just blew it yeah
you know and i remember just going
someone who is
that raw and that close to their
emotions is like the quarterback for a
fucking writer's room oh yeah and
they're the funniest person oh wait
like she is so damaged she's that she
just might work
like i know she is funny like she's
literally on the verge of tears
at all times you're hired and you know
what else i liked about her
anyone that is working in a job where
you're not sure
if you uh how you work like people we
all work differently right
the same way we all remember things
differently like if i need to learn
something i'll make a song out of it
or i'll record it on voice memos and
listen back to it that's just how i
learn
i'm not a very visual learner i'm a very
audio learner
knowing how you work when i first
started writing on the roasts i was not
good in a room
like i wasn't like snap snap snap snap
like i would just get shut down because
i
at the time i was just too insecure and
i was like so worried about laughing at
everyone else's jokes
to make them feel good that i wasn't
thinking of my own jokes
whereas in a writer's room you kind of
just have to like you know
not laugh at anybody else it's it's
always it's also weirdly competitive and
stuff
and then i would go away and write for
two hours alone
and pound out four pages of jokes and
then send them in yeah
that's just how my brain worked yeah
that's how lauren was too in a room
she was kind of quiet but then she was
the sniper who would you know
and i started learning i was like lauren
you want to just break off and she'd go
off and just send in
10 pages of brilliant jokes i've had the
exact same experience with her
she wrote on a web series i did for mtv
called esther with hot chicks like
literally maybe eight years ago and she
was quiet
and then she was the funniest dude
she made it complete quiet with
weak not the best lesson of that because
she
you ca i can't do anything without her
punching it up she is so funny
it is she lives and breeds comedy
writing but at the same time
who she is it just doesn't make any
sense but the loudest
person is not necessarily the most
talented is not necessarily the most
competent it's not necessarily the
funniest or the best at their job you
know ben and i fight about this all the
time
because benton when he's quiet i fill in
the blanks with my own insecurities it's
this awful mad lives game i'm like are
you mad at me what are you doing why
aren't you talking to me and he's like
i'm just focusing
like i i think that i have that with
dave too insecure people sometimes we
think that the person in the meeting
that talks the most
is the best at their job and that is not
necessarily true yeah it's interesting
learning all these things like
it's like oh we've been around the block
we know something i know it's because
i used to just like i was the person the
meeting that was like talk the whole
time
but say nothing of value my favorite
person the meeting
says nothing and then speaks at the end
just hold let everyone else embarrass
themselves
do your research do some recon let
everyone else screw up raise your hand
and have the fucking solution
be the fucking mic drop you know be the
sniper
that comes in later be quiet be quiet
advice we're giving women be quiet lean
out do not lean in
lean out shut your poor mouth
okay i'm obsessed with this company hold
on this is we're taking a break to talk
about stitch fix but i want to pull it
up on my computer because i was on their
website will you start talking and then
by the time
yeah i find it all chinese i'm really
very thankful for this company
sorry i'm stitch
um sorry that was a fart i'm super super
thankful for this company because uh you
need it
you need it desperately and you need it
truly and you know what
i'm fine with that like this company
they do these incredible styling
arrangements where they pick your
clothes fruit you take a quiz
and you tell them their sizes and
they'll send you the clothes you should
be wearing
yeah so you're not really we all need it
so you're not left your own devices like
me because i
am constitutionally incapable of just
buying versatile basics
yeah and they will send you clothes that
first of all fit
which you know when i order clothes from
most uh websites
i three i order three i order a small
medium large try them all on and then
return the two that don't fit because i
never know what's going to fit
ever but stitch fix they're it's
basically a personal styling company
that makes getting the clothes you love
effortless in a time where everything is
difficult this is not written on the
copy this is me just
for you they give you the clothes you
need not the clothes you love
because nowhere in the quiz does it say
do you like shopping at gas stations
there are no options to have nine
vintage wolf shirts delivered to you but
i won't do it
stitch fix and i are gonna talk about it
we're going to get we're going to have a
creative meeting
but no this this company is amazing
because you know sometimes you go
shopping and you come home and realize
you have no clothes that you can
actually wear to work
or that you can actually wear to a
wedding or you could actually wear it a
professional environment you're like
i have nine velour vintage running
shorts
and i got two pairs of you know uh
crocodile knee-high boots for the club
but i don't have a
i don't have a white oxford shirt for a
freaking zoom meeting
um so what they do is they basically
you go to stitchfix.com whitney
set up your profile and they're going to
deliver clothes
personalized just for you color style
and budget which i love because
i also i wear like four colors yeah i've
picked four colors they're the ones that
work for me and i'm just like only semi
stuff in this cause
there's nothing more annoying when you
find something really cute and it just
comes in only one dumb color
and you're like god damn it yeah like
chartreuse like what is this yeah with
cerulean
you pay 20 for a styling fee for each
fix
which is credited towards anything that
you keep
right so you can schedule at any time
there's no subscription
required if you're commitment phobic and
shipping returns and exchanges are easy
and free
if you're not looking uh at the youtube
i'm holding up
this dress that i really really want but
you are looking at this how cute is that
oh well if you're not look on youtube
i'm on the stitch fix website hold on do
you see that's beautiful how cute it
looks like the galaxy yeah it's like a i
don't think they would send this to me
necessarily i'm probably not hip and or
young enough
but it's this really cute navy blue
dress that's like knee link long sleeve
that looks like paint splatter
constellation and i really yeah
everything is gorgeous and the fact that
they they
cater to your style and your budget is
really unique
and i also yeah it's like going on 50
websites to look for clothes it's like
it's 4 30 by the time you're done
looking for
one outfit you don't have to type in
horses in every search box on every
website
this one will just find them all at once
get started today at stitchfix.com
whitney and you'll get 25 percent off
when you keep
everything in your fix stitchfix.com
whitney for 25 off when you keep
everything in
your fix stitch fix dot com
slash whitney benton first came in this
morning with a sussex accent
which i love how how was that it's
can you read the copy in it please about
article furniture
i mean i have to get into it you look
gorgeous
you look beautiful today it's article
when it's time for a change your home is
the perfect place to store
article makes it easy to create space
that reflects
for you personally keep your eyes peeled
and your instagram open for
inspirational features and articles
latest collection darling
um is that pretty good yeah that was
actually very impressive
it's it's almost too good to be too
funny i was actually just like wondering
if you had a dialect coach
um for this podcast they can teach me
everything but english
okay so i'm obsessed with article
furniture uh
truly no shirley is obsessed she has
more outdoor article furniture than she
has outdoors
i i got i i think that my home style is
so weird
that i just can never find any furniture
that i like and it's
it's so much pressure because it's such
a commitment you're like the idea is to
have this forever like
i change my style my hair my eyeliner i
i don't wanna have to change my chair
once a year like i want something that i
know my future self is gonna like and
everything i see on that website i know
i'm gonna like in 20 years yeah you've
loved everything you've got both i mean
i love everything i have too my favorite
uh i have two outdoor chairs that i got
that are almost like this really like
chic
like scandinavian rustic modern
there it's just like it's just like a
perfect architecture and then didn't i
just ordered it
and we built those chairs and they were
super easy to put together yeah
i and then i appreciate because i hate
ordering furniture and it's like
40. it's just like a nightmare i know
you like get a sciatica trying to
assemble them
and then what was what did i just order
i was like you ordered two more outdoor
chairs i know but they know they're
loungers
they're these gorgeous gorgeous loungers
that i'm gonna put outside my bedroom
it's like your
antoinette you need a fainting couch
everywhere you go
like at any moment you can just pass out
i need the opportunity to lay down in
case i get the vapors
could you imagine oh but i mean we
almost ruined our friendship with me
making sure you ordered this article
because you asked me she doesn't send a
link she'll like order this it's not
like i did it and she's like did but did
you order it but where is that and i'm
like i did order it'll be here the end
of may you're like but did you order it
no i lied it's a fun game i like to play
article combines the curation of
boutique furniture store with the
comfort and simplicity
of shopping online articles team of
designers focus on beautifully crafted
pieces
quality materials durable construction
dedicated to a modern aesthetic of
mid-century this is the perfect way to
describe it
they know how to describe it maybe i
should just leave it to them mid-century
scandinavian
industrial and bohemian that is the
perfect way i mean
gorgeous furniture if you get it i mean
everyone around you will be like
i'm sorry are you the most successful i
know what i know i know it's just like
it's all so chic it's so classic
it's so um what's the opposite of corny
it's like
um jams yeah potatoes it's just like it
it just it also is so um scrumptious
like it's like uh very uh effortless
yeah delicious
i don't know i can't you guys got the
point right i can't explain it it just
makes me feel so fancy it makes me feel
like such an adult
uh also ridiculously fair prices you
save up to 30
off traditional retail prices you know
me i've open
other websites constantly and look for
chez lounges and i'm like i'm not paying
two thousand dollars for like i just
refuse
i don't lounge that bad yeah honestly
i'd rather lean yeah
i'd rather lean against the wall than
pay that you can't really relax in a
lounge chair if you if it was five
thousand dollars i'll all i will just
lie there resentment this is your life
savings you can't relax i know there's
nothing relaxing about it knowing that
you paid a reasonable price is half of
why it's relaxing in the first place but
article
they're super fast shipping that's
contactless now they got right they drop
it off right
free on orders over 999 dollars
oh yeah offer is uh article is offering
our listeners 50
off your first purchase of 100 or more
go to article.com
whitney and the discount will be
automatically applied at checkout take a
picture of it and send it to me tag me
i'll repost it that's an amazing deal 50
i know that's crazy and we're at home a
lot now so now is the time it's summer
to
refresh your patio or front yard or
bedroom that's article.com whitney to
get 50
off your first purchase of 100 or
more i love article there uh everything
in the background
of my photos in my backyard are article
furniture if you want
to see some pieces at this point that's
true
as women and the men listening this is
important uh
to know as well like that it has taken
so long for us to get a seat at the
table that it's like i have so much to
say and like i really need to like prove
my worth and i think
you know there's this sort of urgency to
contribute and to finally be included
and we feel like we have to like
earn our spot that we already have it's
it's fun you get the spot and now it's a
date it's a daily countdown to when i'm
gonna lose this
you know this has to be ephemeral and
you know i think that for me
in what i do i talked way too much in
meetings all the time because
i was so insecure that people were like
cause now there's this new moment where
people go oh you only got that job
because you're a girl
whereas it used to be you didn't get a
job if you're a woman now it's like oh
you just got that because we have to
meet like a girl quota yeah
and and i always wanted to prove i
didn't just get this
because i'm a girl and they needed to
check a box
you know what i mean yeah so i over
compensate
um speaking of overcompensating i
good segue like a true comic i found
one of my favorite i have a couple
things for you okay so
and by the way you know what we're gonna
do after this
what i'm gonna let you go through my
purse
okay okay uh esther does this brilliant
thing on her special where she goes
through audience members purses and it's
so fun to watch i cannot wait okay so
i found so my what is one of my favorite
eye products oh
i it's the glossier skywatch
but but there's a catch i brought it for
you
in the worst color that it comes in
i think i'm wearing the worst color
eyeliner right now called lawn yeah
open it up it's so i don't know how
anyone makes this work it's for the i
call it the whitney challenge is you put
the ugliest color on your eye
and then you post it all over social
media a color that you have no chance at
it making you look better or flattered
it's absolutely horrible how sick can
you make yourself look
this is for you and i do think it needs
to be the witty challenge and everyone
needs to do it i would like to be clear
that
on the podcast table is this yellow
which is what i have
i don't see it weirdly you are making it
work you
think in person it's looking like it's
it's making your eye color pop so i am
ready oh my gosh this
truly is the whitney challenge this is a
shrek
how about this is literally just the
color of baby shit
but bye and i have to try to make this
work
by the way there are so many hot girls
out there though that love this and this
color and i don't know how or why
is it eye liner or i should say it's a
shadow so
you know you can like line the just the
where you have your
liner now oh you're gonna oh no she's
doing it now we're gonna do the whitney
challenge oh no
right now oh no oh no we have to stop
am i losing sponsors as i do this right
now is article furniture dropping out
as i do this ritual vitamins is like
we're good
is anything happening how's it i put it
over yellow yeah so it's gonna be crazy
oh there we go i can put makeup on
without i've seen you do this
which is really sad i've seen you pre
pandemic just pull
out in the middle of a comedy club and
put your dirty ass
finger into a concealer and rub it on
your face
you're just like filthy sometimes
the animal this is my concealer
that i literally before i do anything
i just stick my dirty ass finger in it
and then do that
it's it's quite gross and then right
here
i need that yeah i know i need to like
you got to do it a little bit around
your lip sometimes yeah
okay so i put a little bit of i did a
little whitney challenge but i think
this is like the
green and the yellow mix it kind of
looks good do i look jaundiced
it kind of looks good damn it how ill
did that
i like how did they come on here just to
try to make me look ugly as hideous
like mean girls this is genius okay so
we're gonna start the whitney challenge
in honor of esther
it's definitely an honor of you and
whatever for whatever sick reason
how did this start how did the the
colored eyeliner thing start
i lo i feel like you came here today
with an agenda i feel like you've been
thinking about this for a while
i have because the blue i loved the blue
really but then it's you know what you
did you do what dave says i do which is
like you take a nice thing
and then you make it sick you it's like
because once i started cooking and
cleaning in the pandemic i was like oh
my god like this is so cool and then i
and then i made it sick by saying like
now you need me
now you could dave you could never leave
right right right for you so you're
is it pathologize is that the word i'm
looking for yes yes yes
no i can turn anything into a sick
codependent addiction like
anything that starts out fun will then
turn into some kind of
uh obligation or uh sick addiction
or way to hurt myself um this
i don't really know how this started i
think i just started going full jack
nicholson in the shining
with having to be home for those of you
that don't live in california california
has been shut down
four months yeah and i have left the
premises maybe
twice um and i was just getting so bored
that i started ordering colored
eyeliners and putting on like
electric blue eyeliner because
fuck it i never got to have like a fun
twenties and i feel like i'm having it
now i i i relate to
i'm like the mom that's gonna steal her
husband like her
her daughter's boyfriend i'm just like i
never had my 20s like i feel like that's
the route i'm going um i i don't think
any of it looks good it's just
it makes it entertains me i think it's
cool i think it's good for the makeup
the pro makeup movement
yeah we need you we need someone who's
going to experiment especially like a
casual quarantine way
you know a lot about makeup i do yeah i
think another confidence
but you had a big makeup uh youtube uh
no
so i have a makeup podcast called
glowing up which you will be on
i'm warning you i would i truly love to
and we talk a lot about like skin care
makeup food like we're obsessed with
what celebrities eat
yeah stuff like that oh interesting
we'll have you on there i would love
i would love yeah i don't i don't really
know how this happened
i also i think it also this is so gross
but that's what we do on this podcast is
we like
tell our deepest darkest secrets i wear
too much lip gloss
i thought that was my everyone's got
their thing eyeliner
mascara blush like if you could only
wear one thing what would it be mascara
mascara okay
interesting yeah mine would be
foundation
right whoa
scary no well it's been a pleasure
and mine would be foundation that's what
i'm the most insecure about
um but i always wear like too much lip
gloss and on the podcast it just looks
crazy
and i also uh started getting zits
around my lips that like looked like
herpes so i was like i'm going to stop
wearing
so much lip gloss and then i was like
but i got to go crazy with the eyeliner
just attention at all costs really
does at all costs bad attention i'll
take it i also think like as i get
older like i don't it's weird i i when i
was younger i was like
so precocious and that was my thing and
i like dressed like annie hall and like
wore blazers and i feel like now i like
dress from
like the kids from stranger things and
i'm like wearing colored eyeliner well i
do i'm like benjamin button
i feel like when we were doing stand-up
like you know 10 years ago there was a
little bit of a pressure to kind of
dress like a guy
don't ever show anything huge like don't
let them just be distracted by your
chest
yes hide it all and now i feel like
we're just finally
becoming a little you're allowed to be
feminine yeah that said i am wearing an
oversized t-shirt and sweatpants
and that is just who i am um as dave
says i dress like a celebrity
who just got off a like six-hour flight
i would say you look like you're dressed
like a celebrity who just got out of
rehab but okay oh that's true that's
true you do say that all the time
um but yeah no it is fun to kind of like
feel
that's interesting you and i were
facetiming uh and
i was like it was like a weird and i was
like you have boobs that is so weird
like same thing in our business like you
can
know someone for years and have no idea
the shape of their body because of the
way that we have to dress to try to not
make male comics want to fuck us
or not make it our fault when they do
that's true how could you
beguile me with that waistline i see
esther
like coming down the hallway and i'm
like is that a sleeping bag
like what are you wearing what is hap
is that a snuggie is that a slanket
i mean you do really dress it's i don't
i can't tell if it seems healthy
is it like have you out like zippers or
just not
you're not a zipper person that's just
never been for you
i like to be comfortable i respect that
thank you i do it doesn't sound like i
know i know i
i just lied and i felt it
i actually cannot lie as someone who is
a pathological liar in my entire 20s
i don't do it anymore and i'm rusty and
that was a horrible i was i literally
was like i know i respect that i looked
up into my head that was like
lying 101. uh i just lied to you
uh that's called authenticity folks i
i i don't i okay the truth is
i did am i like a creepy old man
i did love watching your special and see
you all dolled up
and i remember going why does she hide
that cute as a button body
am i a creepy old man i remember like
why doesn't you dress like this all the
time i was
cat calling you in my head that is the
greatest compliment i could ever receive
and annie letterman is always like
esther you look like you just you woke
up five minutes before your spot
and you were in a panic let's just not
take fashion advice from annie who wears
like uh she dresses like uh like madonna
in um uh desperately seeking she really
does
she absolutely does but by the way i saw
her on your instagram the other day in
like a
like a baby blue jacket and we've we
found she found her groove
okay she found the whitney approval yes
but what what what
women in their clothes is very emotional
right it's there's something going on
when we wear clothes
i think to um sort of solve a problem
well yeah to flatter your body yeah for
me and
what yeah this you oh
i thought it was a compliment and it is
the opposite
i thought she was going what you're so
you have such a flattered
body type it was a what you dress like
shit
okay i don't want to forget this
question oh that i have for you okay
you are you don't think you are but the
way i
view you is as like the queen of
productivity
and i just want to know have you gotten
into a pandemicy
productivity groove and if so what what
is it what advice do you have because i
want
productivity advice from the woman who
is like had 14 shows on the air at one
time
and like that's called addiction um
that's called workaholism
uh you know i for some reason i there's
this
people think that i'm like super
productive i appreciate that and i guess
the person
who is truly uh obsessively overly
productive probably would never think
they
have produced enough so of course me
going you think i'm productive like i
think i'm like a complete slob failure
i do very well with structure i remember
when gary goldman was on the podcast we
talked about this
i think you and i talked about it on
facetime the other day of like how i
i can't just like wake up and have a
willy-nilly like i'll get to it when i
get to it because
it's four o'clock and i've only like
organized my candle drawer
you know like i just can't be left to my
own devices i do well with routine i
also get
really brutal migraines which means i
have to kind of like do the same thing
at the same time every day does that
mean like food and water kind of
yeah wake up coffee food water you just
have to have routine
so i feel like that was kind of my
brain's way of like force
i sort of like thank my migraines for
helping me be so productive because they
force me to be sort of rigid in my
scheduling
but i'm gonna say something crazy you
know i'm so glad that you
asked that because i think i've learned
something this
quarantine which is that productivity is
not necessarily
um i think what you ostensibly think
productivity is so here's 15 pages of a
script or here's
48 jokes or here's you know whatever
you're the
blog you're writing or whatever like for
me the the
my productivity has to do with how i'm
living my life in a way where i can
actually
write about life so in order for art to
imitate life you have to have a life
and i realized as you know there's a
reason my last special was about a robot
i had become a robot in life and i was
not i noticed
i was not living i was i was i think i
was
so obsessed with being productive which
if i'm gonna be honest is a lot about my
fear of aging
and the fact that i have been programmed
to believe that i
am literally a ticking clock
and i'm slowly rotting every day right
i did freeze my eggs um by some weird
uh weird uh stroke of luck i just i
knock that out of the way
but i do have in my head this totally
artificial
stop date where i'm like i can only do
this till i'm 40. i can only be on
camera until i'm 40.
no one's gonna want to see my face on
camera after you know like i've just
that's when i got in this business like
i was getting offered mom rolls when i
was 27 you know
like it's no one wants to see an older
woman on camera
i think that's starting to change and i
think people are starting to realize
actually women like are at their best
like we start discarding women in this
business when they
are at their peak but i don't know who
wouldn't relate to that because it's
like it feels like that in work for our
business but also
like relationships you know like i just
there's there is this rush in this clock
yes thank you for bringing that up
yeah it's i i know i really i'm glad you
admitted to that because i feel like oh
yeah like same like i get it i don't
know i know so many people who are like
i have to find the person by 27. it's
like
you don't even know who you are at 27.
you know you don't need to marry someone
before 30 like you might be a completely
different i mean if i had married the
person i was with when i was 25.
ugh i would be visiting a prison every
weekend
that's a secret to me in dave's
relationship as we met when i was 24
so he's dated 17 different women
over the last eight years he's had so
many different spicy people come through
so that's how we keep it fresh like
four days he's been in ten relationships
you've been in one
i will just say what my mom says poor
dave
or but no you're right like
yeah but you're also you're incredibly
uh
you're seekers and you're like you've
grown together yeah
you know like you have to have someone
who's and also all the iterations of you
in your 20s were already
probably saner than me um now frankly
but
you know i think that i have this fear
that i only have a certain amount of
time and then it's going to be pencils
down
and i think that is a part of why i am
so productive
it's it's really fear driven frankly
what isn't i
also think that i you know
i hate to do this like when i was a
woman and starting in our business like
sunset boulevard or something but it it
i do feel like i had to work twice as
hard
all the time just for people to take me
seriously
so i think in my head i was like if you
just work harder than
anyone no one can say you didn't deserve
it no one can say you
fucked people to get where you are like
i just like that was also a very
intentional way to inoculate myself
against accusations that i
didn't get anything that i didn't
deserve yeah cause that that my imposter
syndrome is already so intense that i
didn't
want that but i i believe that fear can
be a really healthy
engine if you know how to turn it off
and how to manage it and you know what
it is you know you have
are someone that i feel like has a lot
of fear and you channel it for
good things also i mean you've started
like four businesses and quarantine
pathetic i love it like david's just
like what hole are you trying to fill
it's just like what is it i love it so
you started
truly just started a tie-dye clothing
business i did i did bring you some
can't wait you have given me different
instructions throughout the quarantine
so i hope i got it right but let me ask
you a question how can you tell because
you know i mean two broke girls
the show that i made with michael
patrick king was just about girls
starting businesses
that's true yeah like i'm obsessed with
girls that are just able to go like you
know i'm going to start this business i
have this idea i want to make this
jewelry i want to make this purse like
how do you go from
i have this idea to actually executing
it and getting
like credit card numbers you i'm serious
it's easier than you think like you know
i just i started tie-dying i was
obsessed with it and i'm like
i am running out of things to tie-dye
and so i just decided
you just tie-dyed my face with this
green eyeliner you gave me wait i want
to show you what i made for you and then
i'm gonna make you
sort of oh my god it's very whitney
come on it's this is i call this that i
spilled my grandma's wine
t-shirt and matching mask because my
grandma's an alcoholic
i'm obsessed with these colors
you are you said you want a dark tie-dye
you know that pink and red is my power
combo
oh my god that's genius um but yeah no i
just decided
like this was something fun to do and
it's not that hard to build a shopify
it's like it wasn't that hard
and that's kind of been the oh my god
yes
yes i love that bra oh my god this is so
good on with
my red jeans too um the motto of my
quarantine is like i can do that
you know like oh my god i want to eat a
scallion pancake at home i can make it
because my whole life i've been the
person that's like how do you do that i
don't know how to do it
so my motto is just like you can figure
out the things that look scary to you
and that's
that's why you're now looking so cute
here we are
so you basically were like i'm just
gonna buy a bunch of t-shirts that i'm
gonna pay for
yeah and then i'm gonna tie-dye them and
i take pictures of them
and then i throw them online and then i
post about them it's really that simple
i i know it's because i look at you as
like i could never do that like i can't
even wrap my head around that
but see that's the person i always have
been my whole life is like how do you do
that like yeah so now i'm just like you
can do it you figure it out you google
you watch youtube like there's just ways
to figure shit out right that's like my
motto
of being in a pandemic yeah because
we're stuck at home yeah like it's
you can't use that i don't have time
excuse i mean like people are working of
course still
but that's just like where i'm at i also
just think there's something so amazing
about
something you truly enjoy doing and that
you don't even realize could be a
business
yeah it's not this is a hobby business
let's make it clear it is for charity
but it this is a hobby
hopefully maybe someday it'll be a real
business i would love to do
clothing instead of comedy if we're
being honest
i wouldn't mind making that transition
wouldn't be the worst thing for me
um but yeah i am obsessed with that
because there's so many things that i
really enjoy
sort of doing that i'm kind of like
weirdly good at but it would never occur
to me like oh there's a business here
you know yeah like well you are doing
fine i should
be a dog trainer let's just face it
that's true i should be a horse
uh liberty trainer and i think chelsea
party should be an interior designer
and should design chelsea ferretti
should just be the governor
like chelsea peretti is our sort of
third i feel like i just got in on your
friendship i'm like the third wheel of
you and chelsea pretty's friendship and
it's taught me a lot
because like they'll facetime me in the
morning and we'll like talk for 30
minutes
no not about anything in particular
frankly anything at all
it's just more of a like a webcam it's
just more like we watch each other
make coffee like it's a very voyeuristic
thing and then they'll call me back
again at like nine
and i truly my brain is like did they
just pocket dial me and i'm like
hey guys what's up and then i i truly
get confused and i'm like didn't we talk
this morning
and chelsea just went it's called female
friendship i know you
we're teaching you and i just realized
that because again because of what i do
all my friends are like male comics that
i talk to like once every couple months
isn't it weird i'm learning that guys
don't
talk about stuff with each other it's so
weird or to us
you know as you may have noticed in the
news recently you know and i think
i've been in a lot of friendships i
think it's really interesting and i
think a lot of people can relate to this
like
your work friendships don't count yeah
it's full
friendships they don't you know so you
gotta talk outside of work you gotta
like
be hanging out that's not an emotional
support system the people that are paid
to talk to you at work they don't have a
choice in the matter
it's also very recent that men and women
are sharing a space all day
yeah it started like 30 years ago we
don't have a ton of practice
being together 12 hours straight and
like
not flirting or not you know i mean it's
definitely very weird and
i was uh hiking with my lover yesterday
and uh we were walking on a hike
that was the weirdest it was a robot
that's starting to power down
uh do you two be plugged in he's coming
in
a smacker on her
and we were hiking and this
group of like three guy hikers were
walking towards us
and he my lover like waved at them and
was like hey guys what's up
and i was like what are you doing and he
was like i was just saying hi and i was
like oh
like i can't say hi to people on a hike
or i'm flirting
yeah like you know so sometimes you're
just trying
so hard to not you know be this
what they think you are or give them
permission
to then you know enter your space it was
just i didn't realize like how much
energy i just put into like saying hi to
strangers or like making sure it worked
people don't think i'm flirting with
them but also that i'm nice it's
it takes up a lot of real estate in your
brain well it's interesting because i
can see how
and i've seen this happen literally the
last 10 years with so many women
people will assume oh she's mean
but it's like you're just like afraid
like i just like don't want to
like be overly friendly to everyone
because i don't know what that's going
to mean to them
and i see that with every female
comedian i know
except for annie who is way too nice to
everyone and it's a problem and it's so
annoying going anywhere with her
because she's makes friends with
everyone would teach their own so funny
um but yeah it's like oh you might seem
mean but it's like you're just
like i think that safely we also have to
make sure that we like
like remove ourselves from whatever
someone's projecting on to us you know
it's like i feel like
kevin christie told me once uh he used
to go on the road with me he was like
about 40 minutes into every show someone
gets removed
like and he goes about 40 minutes in you
turn into every man's ex-wife
like i think i told this uh when maybe
fred armisen was on like one time this
guy that i got into the show
he like needed tickets emailed me got
him seats the whole deal like 40 he was
laughing the whole time in like 40
minutes in
i made some joke about like guys who
have coin jars you know guys have jars
of coins
you know and i was like something about
coin jar and he just went that's so we
can pay for your
shit like he just snapped like i just i
he he saw like his ex-wife's face like
you know in cartoons when
like um the coyote would see the
roadrunner and it would just like turn
into a pork chop
in like a bubble like that's what
happens and i think a lot of times
people project onto us
you know and they're like i'm like this
feels old
like when someone's like are you fresh
yeah when someone's like are you mad at
me i'm like this feels old
this feels like you're turning me into
someone else your mother your sister
your ex like someone
got like something virgin mary like i
don't know this isn't mine
yeah you know yeah and i think that um
i do think people's default when women
are somewhat
quiet are they're a bitch they're cold
they're frigid and then when a man is
quiet it's sort of like he's just busy
yeah you know yeah and i get it i'm
guilty of it too like sometimes
yeah someone doesn't know someone
doesn't say hi to me and i'm like they
hate me they hate me yes and i'm like
why didn't i say hi
they think the same thing now like that
was and and you're sort of circling each
other but yeah i just think that like
that perseverating in your brain like
that has your reaction to someone not
talking to you
has so much more to do with you than
with them
yeah that's like an opportunity to learn
about your default
inner monologue yeah what would you say
are your main
fears in life i'm going to talk through
your fears
no no no
[Laughter]
well i kind of i feel like you're
allowed to be mad at me about this
um i was watching your special
and i was like literally the first thing
i thought because i am a creepy old man
i was like and i was with my lover and
uh we were frankly being predatory and i
was like she looks
fucking stunning like
like drop dead gorgeous
and then you had the audacity frankly to
challenge
my reality and like say your
appearance well i just was like i think
there's a little dysmorphia going on
not that there's a judgment as someone
who's incredibly dysmorphic i think we
all have some kind of dysmorphia
but i think it's worth like talking
about yeah i get this feedback i
and i'm totally comfortable with it i i
hear you
when i started i'm not saying see
yourself a different way none of us will
ever be able to do that they say that
they've taught me this
they say if you were able if you ran
into yourself on the street you wouldn't
recognize yourself that's how
dysmorphia i always think about that
because you told me that it's very it's
like shocking to hear but i'm like oh
that makes sense
i when i start a comedy this is my
defense and it's just and i'm not
attacking you i know you're not this
is a this is a very aggressive and i'm
not this is a compliment
that is an insult wrapped in a
compliment that i'm not defending myself
but worth noting when i started comedy
i was very different i was a bit
frumpier
like i had just i went to i went away to
college and i was miserable
i gained 30 pounds i was like didn't
feel
a guy had not hit on me ever like by the
way i
hate it let me just say this i hate it
when you're feeling gross and not your
best and someone's like but you look
gorgeous and you're like i need to put
makeup on you don't need to wear makeup
i fucking
hate that shit this isn't about what you
think of me it's what i think of me
yeah so so i just want to be very clear
about that thank you
wait did you just scratch your face did
i do something do you see there's a
little red on your face
i'm scared okay now hold on it's not bad
hold on no just
don't touch me i just don't touch it oh
sorry we're in a
did you i think it was just a little
piece of um like lipstick or something
is it cool it's gone now i think you
just scratched your face and it left a
little more a little red mark because
you're such a delicate flower like how i
look
it's fine now um
yeah i i i needed to adjust a little bit
because some you know that was my first
special so there was stuff in there that
might feel
like it doesn't fit who i am now and i
tried to
cut most of that but i i know what you
mean and we are dysmorphic and we do see
ourselves i think it's important to talk
about though you know i think there's
something really
powerful to me like like
going oh my gosh this girl's so gorgeous
and this is our society is so fucked up
that this is the way we see ourselves
you know it was just sort of like there
was something really powerful about it
and there was something um really
poignant about that
well i i feel that with you a lot too
where i always i think i've said this to
you before but like
you are not what you you don't match
what you look like at all you know like
because you're this like tall
really attractive like powerful woman
but you're really weird and you dress
quite frankly confusing you don't dress
for
what you have it's just it's and that's
you've been a lesson to me that like oh
not every hot girl is like
perfect and like like talks like this
you know you're you're weird too which
has been really
fun for me to learn part of why we're
soul mates but you know it was it was
interesting it really
brought up a lot for me like if you have
a
uh triggered reaction to something it's
all yours
and i remember going like oh my god i
the fact that i was like why doesn't she
wear a skirt all the time like what kind
of fucking
nasty pervy monster am i so nice
you know complimentary i really i think
there's something super
fucking rebellious and badass that we
just get to dress
like we shop at gas stations like shit
say it like shit you know like i just
feel like there's so much shit
like i was um fighting with uh taylor
tomlinson the other day i mean it was a
it was a real fight i mean it was like a
full
because there was a comedian who i think
is brilliant
female comic who was wearing in one of
her specials like
like a shirt that was just like a little
sloppy like
the way that i dress all the time
frankly and i was like why isn't she
like dressing up a little bit it's her
special like
i want everyone to like be a tv star and
i'm like and i'm like
fully male gazing at being like and he's
she's like are you telling a woman like
are you trying to say a woman should
dress sexy and i was like i think i
am like i guess i'm sexist like what is
this like
i really have so much old nasty
programming yeah about how
i do too should dress i absolutely do
too
and i fully boycott all of it by
dressing
like a boy from the 70s but i definitely
um i get so controlling about how and
triggered about how other women dress
but i think there's something cool to
that because it's it's like oh you have
your own taste you have your own idea
and i think i always respect that when
someone has a take
yeah because that's like a comedian
thing yeah that's cool what is your
advice
uh to people in relationships how to
sustain um i have none it's
well i'm in awe of you be s be
committed like despite whatever you know
it's like
you just know you're staying so it does
not
matter what has been said what has
happened
like and also once you go through a
certain amount of things in a certain
amount of time
you're just you get through it and
you're like oh we're just like family
now
and this is incest yeah
we're like there's no one i could never
re
go through all of this with anyone else
it's like we're just stuck
like and it's but that's out that's kind
of like the shitty way of putting it
no that is no that's it's bril it's so
simple
but also so brilliant and um
uh a good girlfriend of mine who jenny
goodwin who reminds me a lot of you
actually uh she said to me once she just
went
i'm like why are you always in such a
good relationship she's in this amazing
marriage and i'm just like what
and she goes uh she realized she goes oh
leaving's not an
option so when you fight yeah is not an
option
and it's something that i never thought
of before because the only leverage i've
ever had is well i'm gonna fucking leave
right you know and you use that and you
play that card and you want
that's how you're gonna control the
person it's like i'm gonna if i'm here
what control do i have over you
yeah only so i and as someone who saw
people break up a lot
yeah i i just thought oh if things get
hard you fucking leave
right you know but the thing is is like
i know that if things get hard
it's like something that i'm it's like
something's wrong with me
and i have to go through something it's
not like i i had this like big kind of
mental break in january where like i was
just kind of freaking out about my life
and i remember and i was like at one
point during it i was like maybe
dave is the problem and like the next
day i was like
dave is not the problem i need to go on
medication
like he's but you know what i mean like
you just kind of
it's easy to go through a depression and
think oh it's the relationship yeah it's
just it's easy to like
to point that as a problem but usually
that's not the problem i mean obviously
it can be the fact that i think the best
man ever is the problem is
probably exactly yeah that you
might but my point is it's not like i'm
in some relationship where i'm like
everything is perfect
he's amazing and like we just can't stop
touching each other yeah
no like we're just real we're honest
we're like
i'm like just shut up right now i just
sometimes i'll be eating together and
he'll be asking me questions and i'm
like
i just want to eat right now like i
don't want to talk while i'm eating and
he's like okay thanks for telling me i
love that that's because that's my thing
don't you run out of shit to talk about
yeah i am so in awe of people in long
relationships i'm like oh
like how was your day like it's a
groundhog day it's like dude
like i do need to be able to be in
something where i can go like can we
just take a day
where i just don't talk it's like you
need that
i need that i need a lot of time to
recharge
that's what we have too and also like
he'll like do this thing where he'll
tuck me in like
he'll say goodnight to me i go to bed
and he goes and does
like work and i put my hair in pink
tails
and put on a little school girl it's
like super normal
and almost every night i'll be like
he'll be like okay good night and he'll
be walking out of the room and i'm like
what are you gonna do
and he's like stop asking me that he's
like don't ask me what am i gonna do i
can't stand it you know what i'm gonna
do so it's like
just i'm gonna go jerk off to porn
just like the ability to that's but i
like that in all my relationships
friendships just the ability to be like
shut up yeah ask me that yeah like
you're annoying me yes yes
okay and a quick recovery time of not
internalizing yeah you know like
like that i think it's not about the
absence of fights it's not that there
are never going to be arguments it's
about if you're able to deal with them
maturely
not blow them out of proportion and
recover quickly forgive quickly
yeah but i think that i don't want to
blow past this because it's like i do
think so much of the way we have
altercations with the person we're in
relationships with
hinges on but this could end
this could be it so if you're just like
we're in this it's like all of a sudden
the things you're fighting about
yeah the things you're fighting about
just sort of get de-escalated because
you're like okay well what's gonna
happen we're staying together so what
are we doing here like let's just skip
to the end of the movie here we know how
this is gonna end
why are we doing this but by the way i
don't wanna come on here and talk like
oh we're
together forever it's perfect like we're
engaged and that was for me what was
really important is and that's why
he hates when i say this but i a little
bit strong-armed him into proposing to
me he hates when i say that but wasn't
like four years in
it was many more than that okay so yeah
no that's not that is the
most insane thing i've ever heard it's
you're not strong-arming someone after
seven years but once we were engaged
frankly he
he had it too good for too long oh no
he's gonna get mad
[Laughter]
once
once we're engaged i got a lot more
secure and i got a little bit more
normal and less crazy
but we weren't engaged and i was like
mad i was low-key like
mad at him for a while and acting out
and like you you know
i had this like resentment that he
hadn't proposed to me but now that we're
engaged i don't even need to get married
i'm like yeah i just have a security
that i realizing i needed i was insecure
i needed that
i love that you can just say that and i
think that that is so important
that it it's important it tells the
world
there's a reason there it tells the
world you can kind of stop thinking
about it
yeah you know but by the way it it's all
meaningless he could break up with me
any day like that's yes
of course fake thing right but it just
for some reason like gave me people it'd
be harder
it'd be harder to leave you know so much
of marriage giving a ring back you know
yeah sort of like
it's a family diamond it's not going
back to you no matter
what it'd be an incredible speaking of
strong arming
you would have to strong-arm this ring
off me in my sleep
you know i do think though i remember as
a person who again made a show about
what's the point of marriage why do we
have to sign something why do we have to
do what are all these sort of like
formalities like what is all these
traditions like i'm the person that's
like
marriage was invented in order to keep
land in the family like i had
all a million things to get out of you
know to sort of deal with
uh what is actually just
frankly fear of intimacy and fear of
someone seeing me completely because i
just figure
if someone sees everything they'll be
disgusted by me right
so i was talking to uh my friend kevin
christie who we've talked about already
on this podcast
and we were he's the smartest he's so
smart when i matter of fact no bullshit
kevin is
kevin is to me as whitney cummings is to
you
kevin is who i call when i need an
answer to something
and he also brilliant artist he's been
doing brilliant work during the
quarantine um
artists are making incredible things i'm
starting to be grateful for this
pandemic
um but he said uh something to me once
and i was like what's the point of
getting married what's the point of
marriage like why do you have to do the
whole thing like write it out the whole
regular role
and he goes weddings are important
rituals so that your friends hold you
accountable
you know so that everyone in your life
like you can't pull a fast one you can't
worm your way out
you can't cheat we all fucking drove to
santa barbara
we put on suits we sat through this
thing we paid for hotels
and we're we're gonna hold you
accountable you know we're gonna bear
witness to this choice you made
and like there's no secrets anymore
there's no rigmarole anymore
you know and i think that i appreciated
that you know like i
i i liked that idea i like that like you
know you get 50 people there
to go yeah we see you and we're not
going to let you be
shady and we're now all acting
accordingly we're a part of this we're a
part of this yeah i got you a wedding
gift
we're not gonna do a secret trip to
vegas like i got you a voss
you know what i mean like i'm not the
friend who's gonna participate in that
shit
you know i we've all made an agreement
that you're not going to be fucking
scummy
you know i i i had never heard it put
that way before
you know i like that your family is here
your grandma almost had a stroke on the
fucking plane
like this is so i i now i now i under i
don't know why i needed to be explained
the value of that ritual but that's okay
i know that's okay it's okay to be you
people that
have to explain very basic things to me
that most people learned at like 12.
i'm learning now dave says i have a
similar thing yeah
you're learning how to live at 30 well i
think comedians are very much like
were the people that mock tradition and
criticize
tradition and want to question
everything and then i'm like oh i get
why this has been being done for
thousands of years
right it works oh actually actually i do
want to be normal
yeah i do yeah like i'm the person i
mean i was in a
fight with someone the other day about
like drinking water
and she was just like are you arguing
with me about drinking water
like i was like you don't need egg
glasses a day like you can get water
from other things like if you have fruit
or watermelon and she was just like are
you
do you have a hot take on hydration
what's the point like why are you
arguing
you know like i think it's valuable to
question everything but there's also a
point where you have to go like you know
what
so esther does this hilarious thing in
her special where she goes through
audience members purses so i thought
i would let you go through my purse this
is a dream but i also that's why i do
what i do
i i also haven't used it
and like i haven't been going a lot of
places so this was my purse like a month
ago
really yeah i mean i i mean and you
don't like empty it out or need
it's just so gonna be bad it's so big
this is gonna be bad
don't go through it okay i feel like
this is gonna be very don't pre
this is esther's just going through my
purse
oh this is how you do it okay hold on
what why why
why whitney why is there a ball a toy
that's a dog ball for when i find a
stray dog
really i always have one this is for
stray dogs huh that is so
sweet wow
oh i've been looking for them they're
mine now these are
so good you can have them you can have
them so gliders keepers
it's like the tiffany's of their gummy
bears with champagne in them
housewares it's called self-care you can
have that
no no i have 10 boxes of them dry sheets
oh
i need that this is the um uh
yeah dry shampoo wait it's the largest
that's not a tr they make these in
smaller sizes for the purses though
oh my god wait oh no that bag is really
sketchy
my wallet okay oh stella mccartney wait
what's that
healing bomb oh this is good stuff it's
called all good bomb
it's just like what's that oh that's a
really good
this is a good lip balm i really like
it's called oil leo
oysso so usually people this is
crazy deep pockets with highlighters
not makeup highlighters actual
office highlighters with the concealer
this is a really good i this is a
sunscreen stick but i use it as lip balm
what uh-huh don't stop don't film her
doing that it's
very inappropriate what else uh
nars lip gloss i'm liking it oh this is
a really good lip gloss makeup forever
oh i've been looking for this you have a
lot of like
oh this is a lip stain this is my
favorite lip stain that i have used
since i was in
college it is the body shop lip stain
i've been using this for truly 20 years
not this spot formulas have been
revisited
maybe need to like this is my favorite
what's that two outs two altoids
you never know i do not want to have
slamming breath that's my that is truly
my nightmare
so many loose altoids at the bottom oh
look that's a lip balm oh i love this
bombed aesthetics i love this brand it's
a lip balm that's like a little
look how you open it what's that loose
altoids anyone
she's just holding onto these a
lifesaver where
the lifesaver is glued to the package
you know when it's been in there for too
many seasons and it's melted and
re-melted and all that
oh there's like powders from all the
altoids
loose gum whitney you're like
you're like rich like you shouldn't have
loose gum
you never know when you're gonna need
gum but not have time to unwrap it
it's so nasty in here it's so nasty i'm
like not enjoying this
i know you you under special she does
this and it's really fun and funny this
is more like sad
oh my god i thought this
i thought i was like oh she's like a
cinnamon stick in her purse that's like
so chic like to make it smell good this
fucking rawhide
this is a bully stick this is a dried
bull dick
that i use to learn stray dogs when i
need to catch them you never know
this is just like the lowest option of
welch
like why i don't even have just lost our
welch's sponsorship
yeah this isn't really i feel like when
you normally do this it's like funny
it's just weird what are these
bent up pills let me see what kind of
pillow what do you think those are these
are
i think these might be ritual vitamins
no they're not i know what ritual
vitamins are those are not them
they have a little powder in them garlic
garlic garlic
ginkgo biloba maybe it does smell like
oh that
take one of these watch out that's
covet 19 in a pill the bottom of your
i'm sure it's something good i think
it's
i mean that was basically the vaccine
you just took no that was definitely
something like a vitamin
i'm sure i know this is the smartest
thing you have and i want to know why do
you carry benedict benadryl that's
i don't know i don't know i
don't know do you like an allergy
you never know when you're gonna need
benadryl i'm sorry that i'm just
prepared for literally anything here's
your pass for when you are on kelly
clarkson on
january 24th it's july
19th guys it's july 19th this is january
24th
whitney does not have hershey's together
she's a faker
she's she's her purse is disgusting
i'm a secret mess i'm secretly a fucking
mess
this is like when you're not supposed to
meet your idols it's just like oh
like this is who you really are you're
just like me
those stars are just like disgusting oh
my god
thank you for letting me do that that is
by the way the fact that that's my
cosmetics bag is art
[Music]
[Laughter]
i when i pulled this out i was like oh
that must be your makeup bag but then
there was a whole other pocket in here
filled with makeup so i'm like oh well
this is not her makeup bag
bitch this is your makeup bag you have
hold on one two three i literally or
have more makeup in my bag than a clown
would try five
six seven eight and there was another
one nine somewhere
wait yeah this one nine and i have two
of the same one by the way yeah no i
know
these are the two of these in one purse
nine ten eleven oh my god you have lady
gaga makeup
oh yeah twelve what am i you have 12 lip
products in your purse
that's more than anyone needs for a for
a in a mansion
and you have them in your purse i never
know what direction i'm going to want to
go in
god that is so crazy you know
this if you see a child that's really
not appropriate that's an
a oh uh oh what's that i'm not gonna
reveal what that is let me see
beta blockers oh i've been looking for
these yeah propanol beta blockers
oh yeah these are great i'll take some
of those home
oh i love that this is a sunscreen
neutrogena
shimmery sunscreen lip balm isn't it
crazy that you can have
40 lip balms in your purse but you know
you literally need
every single one of them so weird i i
have 12 lip glosses in here and i
none of them can be removed from that
bag i need all of them
how is the gaga lip gloss which one let
me see house laboratory
i think it's good i have some i can give
you some extra it's a pretty color yeah
i like the gaga
lip glosses they're good well you guys
it's true whitney cummings is just like
the rest of us
her purse is disgusting she's a hoarder
yeah she's a hoarder but she loves her
lip she loves her lip products
you've really given me a lot to think
about they're i think so i feel like
you've really held up a mirror too
i think and i don't appreciate it and i
fully plan on cutting this entire
chunk good from the podcast goodbye
everyone
uh i'm holding up for those of you
listening and not watching a hot for my
name
what is this a latte okay so this is the
cutest thing ever
i am obsessed with lattes hot for my
name
yeah it's called the ice top for my name
it's half oat milk half coconut milk a
little bit of a marinara
and that has four shots of espresso so
good it's
don't drink the whole thing you drink
four shots of snow i do half of that
so it's this coffee shop in l.a called
day glow coffee i'm not making money off
this it was just like a promotional fun
idea
um but yeah if people want to go to
dayglow coffee shop this is so
it's so cute i also love this bottle i'm
gonna keep reusing this bottle it's so
cute to hydrate myself
this is the thing i'm becoming normal
i'm like into coffee now like that's my
whole personality now is coffee and
tie-dye
i'm i'm normal
[Laughter]
um that's everyone outside of la is like
uh
what what is that what the fuck is that
esther club is esther's podcast yes i
listened to a lot of your podcast uh
your last episode
there was something very soothing about
how the first 20 minutes are just
announcements
it was just sort of like logistics you
know it's a lot of logistics
set in a very charming way it's a lot of
like apologizing for how she's
saying something it's like it's kind of
fun to just hear her say something just
very simple and then completely unravel
about
the way she said it and then she's like
trying she's like fixing her hair and
makeup
like spiraling like she's just it's what
you'd expect it's really just like a
being inside her mind uh and it actually
was a fun
journey it was like going through a
haunted house um
and but there's something really
soothing about it because when i do
announcements on this podcast i'm so
full of shame that i do like really fast
like like subscribe and read our
podcasts and do the comments like i'm
there was something really hypnotic
about it she was just like you can text
me at my new community number
you guys thank you for what's the number
do you have it yes i
oh god so this is the texting app that
i do you guys text me i text you back i
send you birthday messages every day if
it's your birthday
818 until i die eight one eight two
three nine
seven five two seven you guys can text
me and you actually explained how
you have to log in and put in your
birthday and where you live so that we
can target
our show you did our shows to you
for when we come back on tour so if i'm
going to orlando i don't have to blast
the whole world my orlando date i can
just text orlando people specifically
and by the way sorry
salt lake city alabama arizona
and san diego thank you for letting me
text you directly you guys are why i
decided to reschedule the show because a
lot of you guys were like
wow i live with my grandma i have an
autoimmune thing can you
you know i texted with people directly
in those cities to tell me if i should
keep the show or reschedule that's
that's bad that was really helpful yeah
my number is eight four
seven six four eight nine zero nine
eight and i am
obsessed with this because i like
the same thing is happening what's
happening to me that happens to all
comedians it's like you're leaving
seattle and everyone's like where are
you coming to seattle and i'm like i
just fucking
and i get mad at them and they're mad at
me but it's like no one's fault that the
instagram algorithm didn't like me this
week so this is like if you're
interested in updates because for those
of you that don't know instagram and
please correct
me uh the men in the room that generally
probably know more than me about
technology and that's how i'd like to
keep it um i'm a
luddite by choice it's the instagram
algo in order to get an algorithm the
main feed you have to get a certain
amount of likes and comments in the
first like minute right
i think like there's something
it's called the patriarchy
the post velocity whoa the torque
so if you don't get a certain amount of
likes and comments like in the first
minute
like most people will not see your post
at all so this is a way that we can just
directly text you
i picked 818 because of our friend brody
smart i picked 847 because i wish i
still lived in illinois
um i feel like you and i did have
another level of bonding at brody's
memorial
yeah you were the worst one there
you were because you had been totally
chill like you were like okay we'll get
through this like you were like very
calm
our friend brody stevens google him um
you at the memorial were the in the
biggest
mess of anyone and i think it's because
you
i assume like you're coping before that
was to just kind of be like everything's
fine everything's fine and then you
crashed this is a friend of ours who
passed i was in denial
for yeah the first week i just like it
didn't happen
yeah like i just was like like everyone
my thing is like take care of everybody
else
and then as soon as the memorial
happened i just broke you were like oh
no it this is real like
as soon as zach galifianakis came out
and was like giving a eulogy
it hit me yeah cause you're like zach
galifianakis is at the comedy store yeah
yeah
something really bad must have happened
this is bad so true and it like hit me
and i could not hold it together
i could not function that is the worst
thing about this business is like
getting close to people
who are hurting and having to yeah
i don't know yeah yeah i don't know what
to say that was a wild time saying
anything
that was a wild wild time um 818 till i
die
google it um the guy that i am dating
when i'm dating someone i'll show them
brody's stand up
and if they laugh we can keep dating and
if they
get confused we stop like that's how
that's truly how i decide if i will go
on a second date with a man
if they get brody stevens we can move
forward
and if they don't if they're like wait
is this i don't know why did he just why
is he saying zip codes
like if they don't get it like i just
they're we're done here like there's
nothing else to say
um so uh yeah the guy that i'm dating um
loved it so much and is always like
leather exterior that's awesome yeah so
that's always like in my head
it's funny you say that because on my
first date with dave he had known brodie
because brody did audience warm up on
that show that
dave wrote for and so brody was like our
one
hollywood connection that we both knew
of and it just like put i just will
never forget like
the light it put on my face feeling like
oh my god he knows brody so i
yes are you planning the wedding or no
no do you know where you want to get
married no i don't want a wedding
i just really yeah we've talked about
this before too like i
i don't know maybe one day and now i
have the pandemic to lean back on yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i just wanted the engagement i don't
want to
break up but i also don't want him
weddings interesting yeah
okay i feel like i've talked so much and
i'm sorry and
i feel like i need to we need to release
everyone i'm gonna
stop talking and just let her go into a
complete spiral this is what comedians
do after they completely nail something
and are awesome at something they just
start to spiral into shame
and think that they're like uh putting
people out they just start apologizing
for doing a great job
just gonna put this on and feel safe
just gonna go hide feel my point and
you're good for you merch
benton's not here to say all this but
don't ride elephants
like subscribe i'm very excited to use
my new puke green eyeliner
that esther brought me what is it called
the whitney challenge
the whitney hashtag the whitney
challenge ugly can you get with makeup
that sounds meaner than i mean it too so
we are gonna now
experiment um hashtag whitney challenge
put on the ugliest color eyeliner you
possibly can
and tag us um watch hot for my name
on the comedy central app and then it
will be streaming
i really want to get this right i hate
it when i fucking go on podcast to
promote something and then they're like
anyway and they don't actually promote
the project and i'm like why the fuck
you're
so nice so i want to get it right it it
so
hot for my name the special on comedy
central there's clips on youtube
if you want to just do that but there's
uh the full thing
is on the comedy central app you can
access it with a youtube
tv or a comedy central login i feel like
i
work for viacom i should get extra money
for saying all this a lot of logistics
or after august 2nd it's going to be you
do have to take a quiz
they will send you a code to your phone
this is my style it has to be hard to
find
that's how when you watch it i know
you're there because you wanted to have
to be liam neeson and taken
in order to figure out how the fuck to
watch degrading
how much i have to say i know but you
know what they let us do what we wanted
yeah and i'm happy with how it turned
out and you guys don't have anything to
do and you've run out of things to watch
so you can put in a couple fucking
passwords
um on hulu watch doll face um
and alone together and you're on uh
what else you're on a bunch of shit no
my crazy ex-girlfriend you're on some
episodes of that yeah yeah
yeah so just like binge esther this
weekend
um anything else like and subscribe to
whitney
oh and the esther club podcast and the
makeup growing up
which you're gonna be on yes i'm now
promoting that episode
i'm gonna be on it soon so tune in
alright i love you guys i end these very
awkwardly
please please don't ride elephants love
you
[Applause]